hello everybody hello hello so i needed time a little bit of time to set up everything i feel like ever since i took that was a two-week break i forgot what how to stream and how to talk oh my god my mind feels so slow i forgot how to talk these days um but yes dad is back uh for those who don't know um he came back i believe two days ago um i actually forgot what when i picked him up like time has blurred together like everything has merged together for me so i think it was two days ago i don't even remember um but he is back now he is incredibly chunky now um so for those who don't follow me on twitter which is understandable because you don't have a twitter anymore uh which is also very understandable um let me grab a picture i day being back um so he's dead he is he's back now um sadly he has to go on a diet because he is very chunky right now because of his medication um he was on uh steroids uh for like three weeks because of you know like the the joint pain so the vet put him on
steroids uh because of that he got chunky uh so he is a lot wider now um he's a lot thicker too uh so this is the look he gave me when i was like you're gonna have to go on a diet and he's like no or maybe he's thinking about her um he's thinking about the dog sitter um um but yeah when the dog sitter gave me back dad um when she got in her car he tried to chase after her he was like no don't leave he's like wait why are you leaving no so yeah that hurt my ego a little bit yeah that hurt my that hurt my self-esteem like he didn't care that he's coming back to me he was like look he's like come back no he's like no don't
that hurt my ego a little you know um no no no no no no no no weiner dogs cannot be extra thick because their their backs are way too long that they just don't have enough support if they get too fat so and and they have very short legs so like it hurts their but it's the thing is it like um it's not really good for them because they have such short legs so the extra weight puts strain on their joints and everything.
And I don't want him to get arthritis.
You know, he's already, I already have to treat him like a senior dog.
So I don't want him to get even more senior dog treatment.
So I don't want him to get arthritis.
So yeah, that's why I have to, I'm not giving him any treats or anything.
I'm just feeding him his usual meals.
And then other than that, he has been treatless for the last two days.
Maybe that's why he misses very so much.
um he's been very very weird um i don't know i don't know what's on his mind so like one time like i think this was yesterday um i was like using the bathroom and i forgot to close the door because i live by myself who the fuck is gonna be like you know whoa like watch me so unless there's ghosts but like so i forgot to close my door when i was using the bathroom because i was I got it.
I really got to use the bathroom.
And then so then dad like walk like was and I gave I gave him a toy.
Um, I gave him a toy, uh, earlier.
And then he like, I was, I was using the bathroom and then he like walked past.
He walks past my bathroom with the toy, then walks back to the opening drops the toy and then walks away and i i don't know what he's trying to say like i i was i was so confused because i was like why so so he was like so like he just drops and then i took a picture after i was done because i was like why were you doing what why did you do that like no And then I like,
I don't know, like, you know, I gave the toy back to him and he didn't care.
He was just like, I'm sleeping.
What are you doing?
He didn't even look at me.
He just walks past the door, drops the toy, and then walks back to his bed.
And he didn't even look at me.
I was so fucking confused.
I was like, I was like, do you want to?
play and then I brought the toy back to him and he didn't care he was just he's like what are you doing like he's trying to send a message I was like oh dude why did you do this also I have a series of pictures that pictures that need to show you guys it's like a little adventure so um this morning when I woke up um when i woke up i received a giant ass package like it was like as almost as tall as me and i was so confused because you know i woke up in the morning i was like okay it's walkies time and then like um um i opened the door dad went out first and then you know i was really tired and groggy and then like I try to get out and then there was a giant ass fucking box in front of me and I was so confused I was like what what what is this I was like in the morning too because usually my packages don't get delivered in the morning it's usually like in the afternoon slash like midday where I receive packages so I was like what's this doing here like who sent this to me and to give
like a visual of how big this package is um um I have a size comparison and of like dad and like I try to use my nendroid not my sorry my good smile plushie as a comparison but then he was yeah it was called fat boy too so I was like what the fuck is this was how big the package was I was so confused I was like what is this
Before I, like, tell you, like, I need to show you guys a series of, because I was trying to do a, I was trying to do a photo shoot with the plushie, and look at...
It's like a little, it's like a little story.
It's like a little story right now.
All right, here's picture three.
He knows it's worth it And then And then And then picture Picture 4 And then And then And then it's gone And then it's gone A story in five parts I was trying to do I was trying to do a fucking photo shoot And he just comes in and was like Goodbye Yoink my my plushy now so this is where it started where it started and where it no it survived i got it um i got it back so i obviously i was incredibly confused because i was like what the fuck is what is this fat boy package is this fat boy package for my fat boy for me so and then i looked and it was just it was just stuffing pellets and i was so fucking confused because i was like this is just stuffing i i was like what what is this is it's literally it's literally just stuffing i'm like where did this come from so apparently okay i found out um where it came from and apparently yeah it was yeah so it was a package in two parts so they they sent me the um they sent me the stuffing pellets before i actually got the item and i didn't know
this was the item because they were like oh it's a surprise so i was like and like and there were like issues with like it arriving to me in Canada because of tariffs and customs so because it came from the states so I was so confused because I was like why do I have a two feet tall box filled with pellets like filled with pellet stuffings like what is this doing here in front of my door um so apparently for those who don't know like who don't follow the um um the apex community anymore um uh the apex devs sent me a the newest i don't know what season they're in right now it's it's been so many seasons i've lost count um but they sent a bunch of creators um a package to to celebrate the newest season and in the package was apparently a giant a giant ass nessie beanbag um for you to sit on So that package didn't arrive to me because Customs was like,
what the fuck is this?
They've yanked it and like jailed the package because they're like, you gotta pay fees for this.
So there was, you know, it was literally just a cover.
I don't know.
I think it was, they were supposed to come in two sets too.
Yeah, yeah, they took the Nessie package, but I don't know about, I don't know if they took, I think they didn't take the pellets.
I think they literally just, um, literally just said the pellets were safe, but not the package, because like, customs didn't, because there was no, like, custom sticker, like, you know, when it was, when you get your package for the Canadians out there,
for those who aren't Canadian, I don't know what the American system is like, but if your package gets marked by customs, um, There's, like, giant stickers on your package that's, like, inspected by customs, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So, like, I would always get, like, these giant red stickers where they're, like, inspected by customs if it got, like, if it got, like, marked by them.
And so, but the beanbag pellets, the giant-ass pellet box did not get inspected by customs, because they're, like, I don't know.
They're like, who would fucking hide a gun in some pellets, I guess.
So, so because of that, um, they shipped back my Apex package back to the States.
Um, they're working on, uh, they're working on like trying to get it back to me, um, because like they weren't able to, they didn't pay the, um, because I was on vacation slash on my business trip in China, uh, when all of this was happening.
So they didn't realize that they had, um, it got inspected by customs and then they had to pay like fees and stuff.
Oh, it got sent back because we didn't realize we had to pay the fees.
So, so I have pellets, but I don't have the bean bag.
I, yeah, I got boxed, but they're sending it back to me.
So, so that's good at least, you know, that's good.
Yeah, so I was just like, what the fuck is this fat boy box in my, outside my door?
Dad's back?
Oh, yeah.
Also, I forgot to say, when Dad, like, dropped the plushie at my door, it was 4 in the morning.
He literally was doing a 4 a.m.
drive-by through my door, dropped the plushie, and then walked away.
Fucking weird-ass dog.
But, yeah.
Today, we are going to be playing Epic Mickey.
It's been a while since the last Epic, I think it was like, what, three weeks since the last time I played Epic Mickey?
I gotta stop doing this.
I gotta stop, like, revisiting games after, like, two to three weeks.
I need to stop doing that.
I need to finish my games in a good, in, like, a faster manner.
But it has been a while, so I hope we all remember what was going on in Epic Mickey.
Oh, my God.
my brain feels like i i feel like a new streamer because my brain feels so slow like i feel like i'm like trying to like remember how to talk it but it has been a while um oh yeah by the way fun fact uh this showed up on my this showed up on my twitter feed and i thought it was so i was i did not realize this was a thing but did you guys this is a very fun fact time.
Did you guys know that drinking Coca-Cola lowers the sperm count?
Apparently studies have shown that there is a link between male infertility and drinking Coca-Cola.
Oh my god.
I mean, I mean, cheaper than getting a vasectomy and you get to drink soda you get to drink you get to drink coca-cola like wait I just like wait is this the ad chat at grok is this true okay wait uh okay and then i okay okay the funnier okay but that's not over the here's where it gets even funny okay um because i was like wait there's no way that's true um but anyway it's not over so i told this fun fact to some friends and um one of them was like oh yeah when i
one of my friends was like yo because it showed up on my twitter feed and i was like wait is this true but instead of going like at grok um instead of going at grok i went to google like uh like an old
So, I told one of my friends, well, I told multiple people, but I told, I thought it was a very fun fact.
So, one of my friends who I told was like, yeah, I know this.
I found out during LAN, and I was like, wait, how?
Apparently, apparently, the Chinese staff at the LAN, At the LAT, we're telling people not to drink coke because it lowers the sperm count.
They're like, no, it's not good for you.
Don't drink it.
I'm like, why would the staff be telling people that?
Like, why?
That's...
Matt was looking out for the good guy staff to protect the next generation of...
gamers.
Yeah, I was like, why wait, why at length?
Because at least they care.
Yeah, so like the, the staff, there was a staff, apparently there was a staff member that were telling the players not to drink Coca-Cola.
Because they were like, don't drink Coca-Cola.
It raises infertility.
players are like what the and then and then a bunch of them started like chugging it down even more because they're like we're not trying to get anyone pregnant so i know i was like
um so yeah that's what i thought that was a really fun fact guys that that's the game right there that's i thought that was a i thought that was a fun fact guys uh i don't i i did not realize that that was a thing until recent until twitter thank you twitter uh yeah that's what i expected would happen um all right let's play epic what a great fact uh what a great fun fact to drop before playing a disney game guys um it is It's a fun fact.
Alright.
Ah, let me figure out where...
Let me figure out what volume I need to put this on.
Epic...
Epic Mickey!
Epic Mickey, okay, 12.0.
Let's figure out what the sound adjustment is for it.
Uh...
Epic Mickey time!
Affiliate, thank you for the five gift ships.
Thank you.
Thank you All right, it's time to be Mickey Mouse.
Oh
Dr. Pepper and cream soda for me then on my third soda of the day.
What did you say?
Adney, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would say it's cheaper like Is it Coca-Cola cheaper than?
any form of birth control or like say it is cheaper
yeah yeah and then raising a child too exactly it is cheaper than raising a child i forgot what i'm supposed to do in this game all right
How to chug that shit?
I mean, Broku, thank you for the super chat.
I think this is a good, yeah, this is a good one.
Alright, I gotta remember which one was the good gun.
Okay, I think we gotta get another world in.
Yeah, it's cheaper than paying for college, guys.
For a kid's college fun.
And you'll need 10 total to get Ventureland, Talk to Thieves Explore.
Wait, do I not have 10?
I should have 10.
What the fuck?
How many do I have?
And not doing up quests?
Found this power spark, and I think you deserve to have...
Oh, yay!
NetEase, you've done it again!
Many, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, what have I done?
Okay, I've done...
belated happy birthday of course ninja uh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear ninja happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday oh shit sorry i got too excited there uh it was a very strong blast i got very
Okay, what are my quests?
Do I...
Okay.
Oh, no, I do have 10.
Scattered by...
Has next one...
And the next one belongs to animatronic Captain Hook.
What the fuck?
I don't even remember this.
Alright.
Can I run here?
Okay, I can run.
Alright.
Oh, I had nine.
That's why.
Yeah, I drank way too much Coca-Cola, guys.
Okay.
That didn't take you long to get her out.
Now I can get this projector screen to Venture Land functioning again.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Let's see, I'll just put this here.
Turn that screw.
And presto!
The projector screen to Venture Land should be up and running now.
Now I get to work on the last projector screen.
It might take a while.
Take care, Mickey.
Alright, there you go, Adventure Lab.
Oh, it's Jungle Rhythm!
Oh, am I gonna go to the Tiki, Tiki, Tiki Club?
In the Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki Club.
In the Tiki, Tiki, Tiki Club.
In the Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki Club.
Where's the room?
In the Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki.
Oh, shit, I sang the...
It's the wrong lyrics.
In the Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tami.
In the tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki room.
I knew I forgot, like...
Look, it's been a while, okay?
It's been a while since I've listened to that song.
Because you can only hear this song in the tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki.
Tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki.
All right.
Oh my gosh, whoops.
God damn it.
How do I...
Okay.
extra jump thing.
There we go.
It's literally the song you can only listen to it in that one place.
The Tiki room.
Really?
No, they didn't remove it.
They just added like they renovated it.
I heard they renovated it because I know like they added Iago into the Tiki.
They did like a they like what's the word called revamped?
No.
Yeah, they refurbished it and they added a disney like actual disney bird like ip birds into the tiki room yes because i know yago was in it now i think they did a version where that stitch crashes the tiki room and starts like singing with the birds because that's what stitch does yeah they refurbished it uh yeah they give the super chat thank you thank you hey toky it's my one six birthday can i get a happy one six birthday happy thank you the super chat oh it's daisy hello daisy wait why am i lagging i'm like i'm pretty sure epic mickey is not that resource intensive
i actually never been into tiki room i've only seen like i vicariously through youtube videos of other people in the tiki room okay there she's me crying over there we should start with him wait where's me why are he crying are you like thought about not crying why do i have to go up here is there anything up here oh this okay stop being depressed okay let me go up here and then grab this chest real quick.
What do I...
Okay, I break it.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, it could be like a secret?
I love secrets.
Okay.
Oh, hey, there's a painting over here.
Can I make this?
No!
Okay, it's fine.
Wait, where is he crying?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, sorry.
You're fine.
Sorry, Shmi.
But you're used to it, right?
You basically have, like, a little, you know, a little thing with Captain Hook.
I know you like this.
Didn't they make Shmi gay?
No, it wasn't Shmi.
It was Lafou.
They made Lafou gay for Gaston.
I mean, look at him.
Look at Gaston, though.
Well, only had...
man, I guess you'd say.
I was, so the captain chased us out of Tartuga.
What happened?
We had to escape, we did.
The captain was hauling us to Skull Island.
It's where we pirates used to live there.
But we get no more.
Not since that machine started turning us into monsters.
Oh my god, what?
You get to be a mecha?
You get to be a fucking cyborg?
How?
What's the negative here?
What's the con here?
My crew turn to idle and mistreat.
My crew once so, shape, ship, now so, so.
Bro, yeah, that's fucking awesome.
Yeah, where's the downside?
There'll be no match for him.
What do you mean?
You're fucking cyborgs.
If only someone could stop him.
We should go to Scarlet and see that machine.
Then Smya and his crew can go home.
Trouble is, the way there is blocked.
Can you help us?
Captain Hook, I mean that awful machine hook.
Chase is clear out of Tortuga.
You'll stop him.
Well, first you have to get to him.
And to do that, you'll need to fix the door opening contraption we broke.
You'll need a ship's wheel.
Not long back, my crew sold one to T.
Slam.
Oh, Damien Salt, the big one who's on Lustruck.
He's got the figurehead.
Scurvy Pat, the sneaky-eyed fella by the mask, he did not have the compass.
Isn't Tortuga like Pirates of the Caribbean?
Did Captain shoot these items?
Bring him to me.
That way I can repair the contraption.
Get all the items back and he can pass through to Tortuga.
Yeah, I was gonna say, isn't that positive?
security okay i need to i'm gonna close some tabs actually give me a sec i gotta close some tabs real quick all right let's see let's close this one all right that should help right let's see all right there we go why am i all right there we go there you go oh it's also it's real just me say you need to take my compass eh not so fast i'm making a treasure of a personal sort and believe it's in that tree house antonia took an effort to help me grow but i call it stealing i'm no legs for climbing if you fetch it down i'll gladly trade you this compass i'm a total this key will unlock the place take it i'll just outright sell you the compass if you like I better have my treasure back alright let's just paint this God my urge to just kill everybody is so strong but I'm a good person Yoki a good person would not say that it means I'm a good person because I'm resisting the urge to kill would a bad person resist that urge no no they wouldn't Okay.
Hello, Daisy.
Another one?
And it's Daisy.
Oh, Mickey goodness.
How did you wind up here?
I'm afraid I'm not looking my best today.
The mad doctor.
We're positively beastly.
Don't worry.
I'll take a look for the rest of you, Daisy.
Where are you?
You know what I mean.
My hero.
but there were a lot of pirates wait you said another one have you rescued donald there's an animatronic donald too oswald didn't know the real donald sorry daisy but we met animatronic goofy hmm goofy hmm wait but oswald built wait but how did oswald build donald if he doesn't knew who Donald is.
Alright, we have bring back all of them.
What the fuck is here?
Oh, I was gonna say, where are his pupils?
Who interrupts Hellsman Antonio's meditation?
Hello, Mickey Mouse.
Did you see me levitating just now?
I am learning to expand my cartoon abilities.
Blackfire, thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Ahoy there!
I'm bosom Blake and most pleased to meet you.
I've been here too long, losing my sea legs, you know?
We pilots are refugees here.
Speak with me to hear the sad tale.
Wait, how do I...
Let's see.
Oh, I have to go all the way there.
Wait, what are you doing here in the land of pirates?
I'm enjoying myself despite the pirates.
The one of them is trying to flirt with me.
jumping jimmy sorry seeing you uh dripping like that gave me a start john marxtoning back home i was the king's finest wait you see that they moving up in the tree like a squirrel i was the king's lookout wait there it is again oh no never mind i've seen a tiki mask staring at me from the top the clock tower over there i did yeah i got all the clock towers oh this is a thing is Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's my one sixth birthday and a one sixth and a few minutes birthday.
Can I get one sixth and a few minutes happy birthday?
Well, happy birthday song is like two minutes.
So you get like two seconds of a happy birthday song.
Happy.
Thank you for the super chat kill.
Thank you, thank you.
My name is Damien Saw.
Hey, you seem like a worldly sort.
I don't suppose you know what the woman went.
Ice cream?
Lowers?
Coca-Cola?
are hard to get here in wasteland but ice cream that would be easy i'm too shy to ask her myself but with the right gift i know i can win her over yes i have a fingerhead but i can't part with it it looks like my sweet henriela it reminds me of her but if henriela were mine i'd give you the Figure it out happily.
There's only...
That only way to really know what she would want is to ask her.
She can be temperamental.
And the wrong gift will surely earn her scorn.
Do you want to give Damien the ice cream?
I don't even know what Henrietta likes.
I don't know her.
Do I give her...
I don't know her like I just I just talked to her like five seconds ago she literally was like there's a stalker she literally told me there's a stalker okay there's Henrietta I just love the outdoors fresh air tree plants the scent of a okay away from that ice cream parlor all you guys kept bringing me trying to win heart i'll tell you a secret i'm actually lactose intolerant and i can drink milk and i'm a cow okay see that's all you have to do talk to women okay it's not that hard okay it's pretty difficult okay it is pretty difficult to talk to women as a fellow woman i'm also scared
Don't worry.
I'm also very scared.
It's very difficult.
Good thing they're not real.
Alright.
Let's go this way.
We go this way.
And oh, there's an ITK mask!
Yay!
I was like, what do I do from here, though?
Pac-cor!
You know what?
You say I could do an endurance stream and finish epic Mickey's?
I mean, I feel like I could.
You know what, let's try and do an endurance stream and finish epic Mickey's.
All right, all right, guys, we're in for the long haul.
I don't know where to go, which isn't very helpful for an endurance stream.
All right.
It's not very helpful, but, like, I think I can do it.
Give women ice cream she eats for a day.
Teach a woman to ice cream she eats forever.
Bruh, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know what to do.
Leather has been eyeing a treehouse.
He's been waiting since that block, Antonio, by the ranch, poor Slav, since losing my eye.
Alright.
Where the fuck do I go?
I feel like I talk to everybody.
They're like, we need flowers, but like, where the fuck do I get flowers?
Oh.
I can come in here.
Oh!
Oh my god, that's the Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki room!
Welcome to the Tiki Hut.
I'm Tiki Santa, Tiki Connoisseur.
Where it has it?
You come for a ship's wheel, hmm?
Yeah, I got one from the same pirates that loot my Tiki collection.
In my Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki room.
The finest trio of Tiki masks you've ever seen.
Now scattered to their wind.
Oh, I got it.
I just got it.
Yay!
Here's your Tiki, Tiki, Tiki, Tiki mask.
Here's the ship's wheel.
you later.
Oh, like what?
What is this?
Restores all of his health.
Oh, okay.
No, I don't need it.
Alright, here we go.
That song is so good, honestly.
Oh wait, I just came back from the room.
Sorry, I just love the Tiki room so much.
Alright, here's the wheel, Shmi.
Uh.
I forgot what did he want?
He wanted...
What did the compass guy want again?
Oh, 20... Okay, yeah, sure.
I can bribe you.
25 tickets?
You're so stupid.
That's like 25 cents in the Mickey world.
Like, I'm fucking... I have like...
hundred dollars and you just wanted 20 no wonder this guy he just wants one ticket more too okay how do i get a flowers though i don't have flowers is there flowers in here this guy definitely didn't went to didn't do economics 101 how do i find he sells a fair price where do i find flowers I don't care why I can't just pluck it from the ground I only want one thing and it's disgusting One whole ticket It's a market rate Where the fuck is the Never settle Where is the goddamn flower?
You won't let me pluck the flower from the jungle Okay
I don't get it.
I literally don't see any flowers.
Ow.
That's fine.
All I have is ice cream.
Wait, can I steal this?
No, that's just a heart.
Where the fuck is flowers?
Where do you get flowers?
I don't understand.
There's no flowers.
I can't believe there's no fucking flower in the jungle.
It's a goddamn jungle.
Like, this is literally a flower.
You want, she wants a full bouquet, too.
She's so goddamn.
Bro, just pluck a flower from the jungle.
It is a beautiful...
Oh, hey, there's a spark.
It's a beautiful flower, too.
Okay, we actually need this.
all right oh my god but she's i bet she's basic she wants a goddamn bro she wants roses like a basic i hate i don't know i'm not really i i'm not really good with taking care of plants i don't understand the gifting of flowers because it's just gonna die anyway
is there a flower shop here i'll never understand like it's just gonna die it's all symbolic it's such a hassle to plants are such a hassle to take care of but to be fair like i've never been really i've like killed a cactus accidentally before because i overwatered it because apparently you're not supposed to water a cactus every day so i like drowned it accidentally
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Toki.
Glad you survived the black rain volcano.
My birthday was a couple weeks ago.
While you're on a trip.
Can I have a happy birthday?
Of course you can, Lolly.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Lolly.
Yeah, happy birthday.
I didn't know.
I was like.
If I just water it, like, because I'm like, every plants need water.
And so I just watered the cactus every day, and then it drowned.
I was like, oh, that can happen?
I'm like, oh my gosh.
Like, I was like, how is my cactus dying?
You, you, I give you water and the sun.
I don't understand.
And then I, and then, and I looked it up, and you can actually drown a cactus, because you're not supposed to water it every day.
How old was I when that happened?
Um, it happened when my parents left their cactus at my place and then like they're like remember to water your plant, water our plants, water our plants.
And I was like, okay.
So then, so then like I watered the plants.
I just did what they told me to do.
I just, I was just listening or I was following orders.
I was literally doing what they were telling me where are my fucking book I'm going back home I don't know where to get the goddamn bouquet this area is not even that big like
do you think Daisy will know where flowers are
okay no it's just it's all it's just about Donald Donald Donald Donald what about me and my
I was just being a...
I was just trying to listen to orders.
I was told to remember to water my plants or their plants.
And I was like, okay, I'll go water the plants.
They didn't say how many times I had to water them every day.
Or like, how many times I have to water them.
Yes, I'm off.
Okay, I fucking...
I swear to God, I'm this close to having...
I'm this close to giving her ice cream.
I swear to...
I'm this close to sabotaging this relationship.
I'm so close.
I'm at the edge right now.
No, because that plant isn't real.
That's not good enough because she wants fucking roses.
I'm this close to starting her lactose intolerance.
Oh, wait.
Someone looked it up.
Okay, how?
What do we do?
Try it.
Ooh, someone looked it up.
Where's the flowers?
Where is it?
I need to go to another zone.
Then what's the point?
Oh my god, I just spawned a TV.
I forgot I had that.
I just spawned a TV.
I forgot that was a thing.
another zone what zone do i have to go to okay where do we have to go guys where is this other
zone oh my god that's fine let's fast pass this shit giving them giving them ice cream knowing their lactose intolerant it's gotta be has to be a few you don't know that it could be like you You know?
I'm so forgetful.
Where Goofy is?
Oh my god.
Work all the way to fucking goddamn Toontown?
Okay.
That is so much backtrack.
How would I remember this?
It's been...
I guess like normal people wouldn't wait three weeks to play this game.
I meant to play the next part.
Is this where Toontown?
I don't remember.
No, this is Junkyard.
Where is the other town?
This is...
Where did the- where- it was the other town?
No, this was the other town.
This was the other town.
Yeah, sure.
It's like $10.
I can afford that.
What's wrong?
If you give a human ice cream made out of human milk?
I mean, you drink human milk as a fucking baby.
Like, what's wrong with that?
Okay, there you go.
Let's steal their plants.
Wait, how do I steal it?
How do I steal their plants?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, is that all your parts, Goofy?
Oh, I found all of them!
Yay!
Oh, gosh, thanks, Mickey.
Now I can get back to work now.
And boy, could this place use some cleaning.
Yay!
I found Goofy's parts.
Thanks for reconstructing me.
It's great how far I'll be all back together.
Oh.
Yup.
I can't wait to get back to cleaning this place up.
I'm going to start with Ortenzia's house.
I haven't been there for a while.
And I think I left the door lock.
Thanks again, Mickey.
Oh, nice.
Why is there footsteps?
Okay.
So.
How do I steal their plants?
I don't get it.
I'm here.
How the fuck do I steal the plants?
What's that over there?
Oh, no, that's...
Wait, what is that over?
Why is it glowing?
Why is this glowing?
Oh, is that...
Is that flower?
Oh, am I making the bouquet?
Uh, Fizir, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Wait, what's that is?
Was that part of, like, partial bouquet?
Are we doing it?
I don't know.
I'm so...
Oh, it is!
We're making...
We're slowly making the bouquet.
Okay, I see.
Eifen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki would go platinum for Google.
What the fuck is Google, baby?
Thank you for the super chat.
Eifen, thank you, thank you.
Okay, we're missing one more.
Where the fuck is the last flower?
There's three flowers in total.
How the fuck did children figure this out?
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, it has to be like...
Oh wait, I remember.
It was like...
It's close to wherever the switches are.
Because, like, that was, like, one of the switches, so it should be, like, one of the other, close to the other switch.
Which I don't remember where the last switch was.
Oh, it's over there.
Wait, there's no flower there.
Isn't the Greg factory?
Isn't that the Greg factory over there?
Oh, shit, hey.
Free stuff.
Or, like, is there another hidden wall here?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, Ned.
I found it.
Time to go.
Get my $10 back, too.
Alright.
Drinking up milk and you can build lactose intolerance, but you will be sick for first weeks.
Generally just a skill issue.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You guys hear that?
You can cure your lactose intolerance.
Just keep drinking milk.
Alright.
Gotta go back to give that cow her goddamn flowers.
All right.
No.
I got you flowers.
Stop.
Okay.
Wait, I got three flowers.
I don't understand.
What?
I need to speak to Clarabelle.
Oh, my gosh.
How was I supposed to know I have to speak to fucking Clarabelle?
Is she, like, the flower master?
Like, only Clarabelle can make a bouquet.
Like,
Only one person can make a bouquet because it's so hard to piece flowers together.
It's the flower gatekeep.
Clarabelle owns the monopoly on flowers, apparently.
The flower master.
She is the flower bender.
There can only be one.
Okay, I know Clarabelle was here.
That's Clarabelle right there.
Oh my god, all the cows look the same.
No, that's Amelia.
Wait, which one's Clara Bell?
Wait, that's Gilda.
Wait, there's so many cows.
Which one is the real cow?
Oh, wow, Doki.
They're all real.
Oh my god, she's back in the other town, isn't she?
Oh, wow, Doki.
All right, you go to the farm right now and tell me if you can tell which cow is which.
You go to a farm right now, look at all the cows, turn around, and then look at the cows again.
Tell me if you remember which cow is which.
Don't, okay, I'm going to, all right, okay, I'm going to pull a video of a cow.
you guys name name every cow if you can recognize all cows name every cow okay that's not a cow i don't know why i talked to her i oh my god that
is she okay all right i don't remember what clara felt looks like that's cow one cow two cows three Where is...
Oh, what is she?
Oh, she's in a house.
What house?
She's in a house.
That's so helpful.
Are you clear about?
No, that's...
What are you in the cow?
Which one?
I don't remember where she lives.
okay can the real cow please stand up honestly oh my god it's back in toontown isn't it i oh my god they're farming me they're firing me out of money i guess i should not have waited three weeks to play this game all right okay all right we'll finally remember how different clara belt is the other cows oh my god in the cowhouse this has to be where she lives oh my god she has a flower on a hat i never got that ice cream i needed for the ice cream cake i don't want to give him one my plain old regular cliques so i baked him a pie instead can you deliver to him i know he's expecting it soon okay to horace who the fuck is horace oh it's the horse it's oh It's Detective Horse.
It's Detective Horse.
You need a flower for Henrietta?
You're not thinking big enough.
You need a bouquet of flowers.
Of course, I can't just pick flowers from my prized garden.
You have to find a few flowers from Ostown and Meastreet.
I will make them a bouquet for you.
Three should be enough.
Okay, I got it.
We already, like, sped running through that.
I say as it took me maybe 30 minutes to get past this part.
These flowers will do nicely.
hang on a moment here you go mickey one bouquet of flowers tell her i said hi all right thank god she did it for free okay i need like i need like my ten dollars back give me a sec
i need it i need to find my ten dollars back i spent so much money just getting here why is like footprints too like where are these footprints trying to go anyway i'm curious where are they where are these footprints this is new where are they trying to go it's so secret 33 2 33 36 detective mickey i speak to see you here aren't you a friend of horace even since this belongs to someone else then by all means take it what did he give me a flower you got what you want buzz off oh my god it's another flower okay what's that quest i didn't even know what that quest was
deliver find missing you've covered oh it's another missing flower there's so many flowers in this world i need another ten dollars okay well i got paint i gotta pay my ten dollar fee again i swear this guy has this guy has like figured out how to get rich just find me i'm literally like their best paying customer if i if i disappear i crash their entire economy
I remember reading this tweet about this guy Who this person who was trying to like Ween off of fast food and McDonald's And like back apparently back in university She would get like McDonald's like every day And then she was like I gotta stop this is a problem And after like two or three months of doing it The McDonald's went bankrupt and Literally she was Holding up the economy for that store.
For that restaurant.
I had to close down after she stopped going.
All right, where's Detective Horace is?
Here, that's a detective agency.
Single-handedly propping up the McDonald's down the street.
Clara was saying to deliver this to me.
What is it?
Oh, it's a pie.
it's just like every other year that's not her fault that's not her fault though thanks Mickey here take this power spark it's the least I can do for your efforts just friends oh they just oh no Clarabelle got friend zone damn they got a entire pin made for it too that's fucked up imagine having a pin made for your friend zone really Alright,
nice.
Damn, that's fucked up.
After all, she baked you a pie and all she got was a pin.
I didn't come here, didn't get a dagger.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, now, now we have the bouquet.
Alright, here's your goddamn $10.
thanks for the pie friend i know right like she literally gave you a pie and you're like oh my gosh what a nice friend i don't know why she only she she picks pies for everyone right
flowers she's just really nice isn't this a human and a cow isn't this supposed to wrong or is it like you see oh
my god she kissed him personally I give him a few months it's a cow woman toky it's different now that I have all pieces we should talk to Smeak again if it's wrong I don't want to be right
Okay, nice.
I got my $10 back.
Alright, Shmi, I got your...
I got your contraption.
Oh, goody.
Okay, it's like Umamusume.
Okay, but the horse girls, they have like a pass because they have the face of a human.
But that's literally a cow.
Okay.
it's like a reverse mermaid is it wrong if it's a like it's is it wrong if it's a reverse he collected all the parts you know like tors like the legs of a human or wasted legs of a human but the top part is like all fish uh as to start blocking the way to tortuga it's better You can continue your journey,
a challenge, captain, hook.
The part that matters is human.
That's true.
Like a normal mermaid.
If you think about it.
Because you know how, like, you know how mermaids have kids, right?
The female just spits, just poops the eggs out.
And then the male fish poops the, uh, poops.
a baby making juice onto the eggs so technically technically like technically a reverse mermaid would be a better experience than the normal mermaid don't keep please i'm frowning
all right you got locked okay let's go to the door which one's the door I'm sorry I got distracted We would not Hear me out Hear me out guys A reverse mermaid is a better experience than a regular mermaid Just put a bag over the Just put a bag over the fish part And then it won't be weird
Okay Okay Nice.
Got it.
I was not expecting this.
Thanks, Toki.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I agree with that one dragoon.
Give her time out, Toki.
Sure, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They booed her because she's right.
All right, where the fuck do I- oh, it's this way.
Okay, I was gonna say, where the fuck is it?
Then...
All right.
Oh my god, barely made that one.
No, she isn't.
Okay, I was gonna say, why can't I fucking move?
How do I get up there?
Okay, I have to do, like, a whole thing.
Look at this, there's a jungle monkey.
Monkey!
Nothing right about this.
Isn't like, we're mermaids invented because the sailors got like, because sailors got extremely lonely.
So when they saw a manatee, they thought it looked like a woman.
Isn't that how mermaids were born?
Honestly, like how the fuck do you confuse a woman with a manatee?
Here, hear me out.
Yeah, I want to go to Tortuga.
I think the lonely part is...
Oh, man.
Oh, yeah, they were probably as loosening.
Oh, yeah, Scurvy does crazy shit.
He didn't have enough oranges.
Make way, landlubbers.
This bit is beginning to appear this for an old sult.
But where is Captain Hook?
Aboard the Jolly Rogers sailing about Skull Island.
Do you know how I can get there?
Should ye be so foolish and seek gentlemen Starkey in the jungle?
Now stand aside.
Whoa, goodbye.
Every day, something new.
Don't forget that we got a fine hook and get that missing part of the rocket.
Okay, fine hook.
Holy shit.
What happened to regular Captain Hook?
Wait, Shmi isn't like a forgotten character.
He still has a Peter Pan ride.
I can't believe Sherman left without me.
And I'm the one that opened the projector screen.
The guides keep me from getting my bag from the far side of the harbor.
I can't flee to venture the animal out of it.
Who?
Shmi!
It's me, the guy that gets abused.
I'm willing to give you a watch sketch for free if you get that bag for me.
What's a watch?
I'm sure your gremlin buddy will tell you when the time is right.
It's good, though.
I have plenty of them.
I opened the project screen to the jungle for you, too.
You get me that my goods.
Okay, he needs this bag.
I already forgot where it was.
He, like, pointed me to the direction.
I already forgot.
Wait, actually, wait, I can paint through this.
And grab.
Oh, I got Daisy's legs.
Ooh, la-la-la.
Whoa, I got her legs.
Ooh, la-la.
Oh, yeah.
My favorite.
I think it's really funny.
That reminded me because I was like, oh, yeah, they made La Fugue for Gaston.
Which I mean, like, come on.
the blood all right oh shit was that supposed to happen yeah oh it was um wait what that up i don't think that rock was supposed to was that rock supposed to collapse like oh it was okay um and i think and i think it was funny because i remember i saw like an article or youtube video being like uh disney has a problem with like try trying to make whenever they make a whenever they make a gay character in disney they always they're they always be like the first gay disney character and there's been like 20 of those they've been like 20 characters that happen to be The first gay Disney character.
Friends!
My friend beam!
No, no, you don't understand.
This is the first one.
Are you not all friends yet?
I wonder.
Let's just hang out.
Okay, but this one is gayer than the next.
last I just thought that was funny because it's true though they every time they're like but first time Disney has ever made a gay character and then it's like their 20th time their power creep me being gay all
right it's like how the first 10 comments are always someone saying first.
It's true.
Friend!
Where's my other friend guy?
I'll become friends with you by force.
Okay, we gotta get rid of this.
I know.
I was trapped in here and unable to help as these mechanical bees herded the pirates off the Skull Island.
I have to save of the pipes here.
That should keep those flattish from showing up.
Wait.
Where?
When was that going on?
Alright, painting.
Oh, wait.
There's something over here.
How do I get past here, though?
Uh...
Maybe here?
No.
Try to figure this out.
Yeah, maybe...
No, that's not here.
He didn't say he left his bag somewhere.
I guess, like, here, maybe?
I really should have, like, paid attention where he was pointing the bag.
I was absolutely not paying attention.
Let's see.
Oh, hey, money.
That must be...
Oh, there it is!
There's his bag!
Okay.
Oh, wait, there's, like...
It's like a painting over here.
Do I make this?
I do.
If I do my extra jump.
Parkour!
Yeah, I'll go this way because it's faster.
This opens up a different portal.
Alright.
We go the fast way.
I'll go the shortcut.
Yeah!
Damn joe boys looted before getting locked up.
Just full of rocks now.
Mind getting them to give it back?
They don't fear me.
But you might give them a pause to consider the error of their ways.
I almost forgot.
It's dangerous to go alone.
Take this.
Oh my god!
That's Zelda!
Watch sketch.
You have a watch sketch.
Ever waited a long line that never moved?
Makes time move almost as slowly.
Oh!
Oh, it's like the TV.
Okay, I don't remember what the TV...
Oh, it's like, it's an activator.
Press LB.
Everything is slowed down.
You move at normal speed.
Imagine if Nintendo...
It's like...
What's it called?
Mutual...
Like, you know how, like, how, like, everyone has, like, weapons of mass destruction, but nobody wants to use it, because, like, everybody has it.
It's like that.
They don't want to sue each other, because...
Yeah, mutually assured destruction.
Yeah.
So, like, none of them wants to sue each other, because they know...
They have a mutual assured destruction.
Oh, I'm so sorry, friend!
It's okay.
I'll give you my friend juice.
Yeah.
So none of them wants to...
Oh, hey, there's the key.
Okay, now can I use it?
Now can I use it?
Where the fuck is that key for?
He said these guys stole his shit.
Like, these guys beat him up and took his lunch money.
Okay, maybe there's something over here that I missed.
Must be.
I definitely missed something.
Let's see what's over here.
Oh, it was just more paint.
Wait, there's something down here.
Oh, there's more keys!
Now I can choose...
So you did know these keys only work once.
Okay.
But where does that open it?
Where are the jail cells?
Yeah, so Disney and Nintendo don't want to sue each other because they know if they try to sue each other, like, it'll never stop.
I assume they have so much fuck you lawyer money that, like, it'll actually never end.
It'll be like a court case that lasts for, like, like, decades.
Okay.
Where the fuck?
The boss!
It's your cold war!
That was a handshake agreement.
Oh yeah, there was a YouTube shirt that showed up on my algorithm.
Oh hey, there's another junkie.
I can let those bad apples out now if I want to.
Which one?
We're all bad here.
The reason why we have parody laws is because there was this one cartoonist that just kept drawing like Disney porn
We're like Because he was trying to like Get like freedom of speech in like Parity law like he was trying to get like Parity law a thing Because there was no fair use laws back then In America so back then in America There wasn't any fair use laws So because of that like Disney like big companies Could like basically sue people for Drawing like like know for like doing anything with their characters and then there was this one cartoonist that hated that concept so he just started drawing disneypoint and like to fight for fair use yeah
and then he got like a bunch of he got like a bunch of artists to like work together
just Mickey and Vinny and other Disney characters banging.
Okay, fun fact.
Fun, not the hero we need it, but the hero we deserve.
Yeah, and then Disney did sue him because he was like, they were like, stop.
And then Disney sued him, and then he took it to the Supreme Court.
They took it to, he took it to federal court, so that fair use, um, and then, and then after he took it to, like, the federal court, um, even though he lost, he technically, he didn't win the case, but he got, he got fair use laws implemented, and he didn't even have to pay for any lawyer fees for it.
he like he technically won the case because he didn't have to pay any lawyer freeze do you have links to this so we can afford oh no that sounds terrible what's the sword
yeah he basically won and that's why we can that's why we have rule 34 he's yeah he's like the jesus christ of rule 34 Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How the fuck do I?
I don't understand You were like what like they open the door let me in
I can't use it unlock this He died so we can sit Like I have the keys.
Maybe try the green floor next to the door.
There's a green floor.
Where the fuck is the green floor?
How is the story not a movie?
I'm so stuck on this area.
I think there's a lot of reasons why it's why it's not a movie yet where else do I go I'm not trying to figure this place out I feel like oh my god oh my god there was a oh wait no never mind this wasn't a secret I was gonna be I thought I figured it out
oh my god I fucking dropped back into the goddamn thing okay
okay we gotta paint this back where i'm gonna keep falling into it i'm like stuck because they gave me the key but like i can't even use the key i don't want to i'm worried about use the stop okay let me i'm gonna use the stopwatch fuck this wait that didn't kill anybody okay no i didn't
yeah oh my god i wasted the stopwatch i wasted the sketch oh my god magister thank you for the super chat thank you thank you that brush has a really healthy stream thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh drg thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh Maybe it's something to do with this?
Wait, it's this thing.
It was a rock here earlier.
Where did the rock go?
Wait, no.
What's the point of this rock?
There's another house that seems to have an entrance from the roof.
Oh, there was.
Okay, let's find it out.
Some of these are not very intuitive.
Unless I'm...
Dumber than a child.
No.
Maybe a child just explores more.
Maybe?
No, that can't be it.
Guys, no.
Stop, guys.
That can't be it.
Maybe?
Okay.
That doesn't do anything.
That also didn't do anything.
Yeah, my Oshi couldn't be Dumber than a 5th grader.
Guys, no.
Guys, I beat 5th grade.
That can't be true.
I have three keys!
I don't understand!
Let me use my keys!
I have three keys!
I can't go down here.
Oh.
Oh my god, we're, like, actually stuck in purgatory right now.
Alright, I gotta figure out where to go.
Are these the jail cells?
What are the jail cells?
Like, these are the jail cells, and I have the keys.
Let me in.
Maybe if I...
Oh.
Guys, I figured
That's it I have a key And I don't even unlock it What's the point of having a key Wait Oh, that's the point Okay, you have the key Alright, that's the That's what the key is for You're not spiders In the fifth Glader This sash down there fixed the gears in that goods.
Alright, let's fix all of them.
Alright, here we go.
A gear down there is hooked to an old ride.
Never had the nerve to spin it.
Alright.
I use a key.
I'll share one of my secrets with you.
At least I'm free.
Parts of an old ride are submerged in the harbor.
Restoring the lamps that used to cause the rise of it.
Wait, how do I restore the lamps?
Oh, okay.
Okay, we gotta paint the lanterns and stuff.
Okay, I did it, guys.
I fucking did it.
It was just that easy.
Okay, there's three lanterns.
There's one over here.
There's two over here.
There's a third lantern.
Where's the third lantern?
Okay, lantern.
Lantern!
Where are you?
Like, it's a door!
How was I supposed to know I had to just, like, un-paint the door?
Like...
I am a hero.
Alright.
Where the fuck is the last lantern?
It's like, the lantern's not here, but I'm gonna talk to them just in case.
Okay.
What the fuck is it?
It showed me two lanterns.
Is it up top?
I don't see anything here.
Oops, sorry.
My little friend Shabim got to him.
Yeah, I'll go up here first though.
Oh, it is up here!
There we go.
Hey, nice.
truth is, I know.
Know what?
A here inside the well is linked to an old line of missing pirate.
Big P needs to help with Petronic.
Oh, I already got that.
Wait.
What was the other hint that he said?
I already forgot the other hint he told me.
What was the other hint?
I already forgot what the other hint was.
Okay, we'll just go for that place first before we try and figure this.
I know about there was the well, but what the fuck was the other hint that he tried to tell me?
No, no, there was a third guy.
There was a third hint.
There were three people I freed.
Guys, there was one more hint.
No, I know about the well, but there was one more.
Damn.
We paint this so we can it.
Okay, we know about the lanterns and the well, but there was one more.
Oh my god, that's it.
That's all I get.
I did all of that just for a fucking pin.
Oh, it's the underground.
Okay, we gotta figure out how to unlock that area, man.
Where the How the fuck do we unlock the well?
Okay.
How do we unlock it?
Will I just unpaint this?
I did nothing.
Oh, it did something.
Oh!
Go down.
Down we go.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
I drained it.
I didn't drain it.
Wait, what's the point?
What's the...
Oh, it's for this.
It's...
I didn't drain it, guys.
The bronze pin.
Alright.
This way.
Up we go.
And then...
And then we open this pathway.
Right here.
Hello, sir.
I don't understand how being a fucking cool-ass half-robot is considered a bad thing.
How could that be bad?
Oh, my God.
Those scurvy spatters are trying to keep...
They're gatekeeping me!
Spin the gears and hurry.
Oh, that's easy.
There it is.
it's just that easy how do i use my
all right there we go and then we got a little cut list damn that was so hard guys i swear the actual post the the the the the action part is like so easy compared to the puzzle is like made for college students and then the action part is where it was made for children.
Alright, here we go.
You should cut this.
I heard Sherman tell you to find Starky in the jungle.
Well, I owe you one.
Since you got my goods back from me, I'll open the projector screen to the jungle.
Head to the one near the water wheel.
It'll be the one on by the time you get there.
Alright, nice.
I found the lost belongings.
This is why most kids got the bad ending.
I think most adults got the bad ending too.
Because I'm going to say is being evil is just so much more fun than being good.
Alright, go to the jungle.
In the jungle.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
The lion sleeps tonight.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
The lion sleeps tonight.
Alright, we go this way.
I am a good person.
That's why, like, I work so hard to be good that's when you know i'm i'm ultra good i'm like lawful good because like it's so it's so hard to be good but yet i do my best being the goodest person in the world don't listen to her lies how am i lying but how do i okay i was gonna say how do i kill this bird um for the sake of humanity how do i kill this bird
i am lawful good guys okay wait we go i thought we could go this way wait i'm stuck oh my god what happened to me i'm not the game was like you didn't see that
Sir, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, Doki.
Yes, I missed a lot of streams.
Did you reach a goal once so that Doki Papa streams him playing for the PS5?
Yeah, we did.
I haven't done it yet, though.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We're getting through all the goals, though.
There's a hangman tree.
The only way out of the jungle is through here.
Oh, that must be Starkey.
We should hurry them.
wait i forgot can i no i have to like wipe his existence and then kill it there you go like they can never be good they were always meant to be evil
all birds are evil not me though not me i'm the exception it's like if a zombie bit me i would be the one that survives the bite and that's why if i ever get bit by a zombie I will I won't tell anyone because I know I can survive it
he's like why tell anyone when you know you're gonna I can tank it guys don't worry I and doom humanity no no no no I'm I'm the one exception I will be the one that that is resistant to the to the virus You suppose anyone have to find them all and paint them?
Fairly, right?
It's just the guy that's in the middle, like, this isn't a zombie, but it's like, no, I just...
No, I got bit by my dog.
No, no, guys.
I will be the one that...
Don't worry, guys.
I'm the main character.
I'll survive.
What's this?
Oh, I got one of the eyes.
See that?
The stone head releases a lock when it's rotated.
Okay.
Yikes, that pilot looks dangerous.
Wait, is this the cyborg pirate or, like, an actual robot?
Wait, can I become friends with him?
I don't think I can be friends with him, guys.
Wait, how do I?
Oh, he's at the back.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh my god, that's so bullshit!
Swing.
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
And then he'll just let...
Okay, I need to grab some HP real quick.
Alright.
Let me use my not friendship blade.
Okay.
There we go.
Each kind of...
Oh, these are all the...
That's all the robots.
Alright.
I still want a treasure...
Treasure Island...
Treasure Planet Sequel?
I don't think that's ever gonna happen, guys.
You gotta move on.
You know what we'll get first?
We won't get Treasure Planet Sequel.
We'll get live action treasure planet.
We're more likely to get live action treasure planet than this animated series.
sequel that'd be me we need to find captain hook be his friends or his foes um whichever keeps me the healthiest we're not exactly friends with hook are you oh please do not curse us hook's got man and the rest of his crew his new crew they'd be monsters but some of us stay behind the fight us reach hook huh indeed i might if you help me first well sure what do you need near hangman's tree stands a stone bear one of three symbols find all three and share him with me then will you tell us the password to reach scull island i but only when you scar the jungle be wary of feather and green tights is fitting about scull island as well if hook sees him that'd be We can't get to Skull Island without the password.
We're fine, you symbols.
What's Starkey give it to us?
Trust the pirate.
What could go wrong?
Okay, but pirates, they...
Even though, like, pirates love to steal and kill and, like, do other horrible things, um, they're very honorable.
They're very honorable people.
Even though they do all the other bad things there, at least they have honor.
They have the cold.
There'd be a handful of villains in this jungle.
Anyone which could lay starkly low.
Say about making them less frightening.
I'll make it worth your while.
Arr.
Oh, there's another stone.
Or jewel.
A jewel is technically a a prettier stone.
If you think about it.
A jewel is just like a stone with colors.
what's over here oh there you go okay so we got one of them oh there's the other stone
these aren't even rare anyway too i don't guys know this but why would someone put lanterns in the jungle i don't know why would people do a lot of crazy shit in this jungle i don't guys know this but diamonds aren't even diamonds are like manufactured rare they're not even like um they're not even supposed to be that expensive it's just because there's a monopoly on diamonds what the fuck do i free you you're all just trapped there
oh where the fuck do i go i'm sure lost anything yeah yeah we can literally make we can manufacture diamonds oh shit okay yeah synthetic diamonds.
That's what I don't...
I don't know.
Also, like...
They're so ugly.
I find...
I don't know.
I find diamonds to be pretty ugly.
There's, like, nicer...
There's, like, nicer gems and rocks.
Okay, there's that one.
In my opinion, I feel like there's nicer, prettier rocks than diamonds.
And diamonds are like...
And I don't know.
Diamonds are just expensive just because there's a monopoly on them.
Why do I have like the most interesting topics on my most e-book games?
We're missing out on part three of Epic Mickey.
People are missing out.
My brother hates diamonds and flowers.
The nerf though is just too strong.
Oh wait, here.
It's the last password.
That's all the symbols.
Let's return this starkey.
Alright, let's see.
That's why you can't miss out.
Go through some insane shit.
Now you have multiple fun facts to share to your friends.
Guys, which one was the most fun one?
Which, guys, which part do you think was your most fun part?
Most fun fact that you learned today, guys!
Wait, why am I here?
This thing isn't even going down.
Definitely the cola.
Except for the Coca-Cola.
Okay.
We got all the hostiles.
I would say that's the most fun part, fun fact.
Is he the password guy?
I'll let you tell you on the path of Scott Allen give you a treasure.
I'll make any pirate cheeks turn.
Okay, here we go.
Yo, bro, you're sleeping on reverse mermaids.
How's it fun, Doki?
You get to save money.
You don't have to, you don't have to pay for college tuition.
Is there something here?
Okay, I'll get that.
I feel like, like, okay, because I'm still missing some rocks.
And then there's the lanterns, too.
And then there's, there's so many things that I'm missing!
Because, like, that's, like, where I have to.
I have to go.
Because there's like people trapped in their little cubbyhole shit.
Oh my god, why are you all missing your fucking eyes anyway?
Okay.
This is a giant ass place too.
I can get lost here.
Wait, I go here yet?
Oh no, I didn't.
So many little secrets everywhere.
Wait, no, I was here.
Oh no, I was here.
Oh my god.
Maybe I have to get a lantern?
I might be missing a lantern somewhere.
It's like they're trapped.
How do I free you, sir?
He's trapped.
Doki doesn't like flowers, doesn't like diamonds, only cares of the bottom half.
We're learning so much.
I'm sure...
I'm sure it's...
Next thing, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What can I say?
I'm like...
What is the word called?
When you're not demanding?
What's that?
What's the opposite of that?
I'm just a bro.
I'm yeah.
I'm low.
Yeah, I'm low maintenance.
Yeah.
Can I say I'm low maintenance?
hate to this.
Bro, I just want to play video games.
That's it.
I just want to play video games.
Oh, I fucking waste money on a wedding.
Fucking buy a house.
I don't care.
People also like, I, oh, what was it?
What's his name?
Was it Ronaldo that finally proposed to his girlfriend after 10 plus years of dating?
And then like, she got an ugly ass ring for it and like it had like a giant ass diamond but um at a giant ass diamond but it was so ugly but it was a big ass diamond oh there it is he missed the gamescom live stream today pro it was like too early in the morning i did not if you think i i chose
You think I was going to fucking wake up that early to watch Gamescom?
I could barely wake up that early in general.
Gamescom is in Germany, guys.
You know where Germany is?
EU.
You know how early that shit was?
I'm so low maintenance.
I just want a house.
Guys.
I'm so low maintenance.
I just want one thing.
A house.
I feel like I've been walking around the same place over and over.
A house is practical.
What the fuck am I going to do with a diamond ring?
Use it as like those knuckle bracers?
Where the fuck is our hitler rocks?
A basic need.
Joki, that stream was just an hour before this one.
Yes, and you know what time I woke up?
It was definitely after I woke up.
Maybe here?
It feels like I haven't been here yet.
Oh yeah, there it is.
There's one more rock.
What do you say?
I don't know.
I've been...
It's the same thing as the other rocks that we're doing, Sparky.
Where the fuck is the last lantern?
There's so many things wrong in this area.
God, they're so demanding.
Oh my god, there's so many rocks that I'm missing apparently.
Brad Lomis, I think it'd be you to the utilitarian.
You value useful stuff more.
I think it was super tragic.
I don't know, I just don't I don't care about like material things as much unless it's got blind boxes and I care
unless it's oh wait no I actually spent so much money when I was in Japan I spent unless the things thing is very unless it's very silly I buy very silly things um oh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i have wasted money on very silly things uh i'm sorry toky but the striker will not let you into their house because i know my return i will no longer have a house to take care of thank you with the super chat oh thank you thank you
i swear to god i feel like i've been so lost this this entire game is It's just me being lost.
I'm trying to find the last lantern!
Cosmo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where the fuck is the last lantern?
I swear to God, I'm going to beat him up.
If they don't tell me where the last lantern is, this guy's going to get it.
He's just like this random stranger, and I'm taking it out on him.
That's fucking right.
Wow, dokey.
The map!
What do you mean?
Check the map!
Look at this!
This map was...
drawn by a five-year-old wait what the fuck do you mean check the map what does this map tell me and it gave a five-year-old a fucking crayon it was like draw what you think this looks like like you're like oh there is there's the last guys i found the lantern guys i found the guys i did it i found the lantern see guys if you complain enough you'll find the lantern eventually Okay,
I remember where he was trapped.
Oh, there's like three rocks that I'm missing.
That's the thing.
There you go.
All right, get out of here.
I can lock down the gate and keep the thinner from pouring into the reverb.
Oh, wait, where's this?
Wait, where the fuck is that?
Where did he do that?
Could he not zoom out for me, like, a little bit?
Where the fuck was that?
Oh my god, that was not helpful.
It was that way, Doki.
Oh, it was this?
Okay, it was this.
Okay.
I thought I already did this.
I get... Oh, because it...
What did that do?
Oh!
Oh, it's... Oh, there's no more thinner!
Okay.
Okay, I fixed it.
Okay, there's no more thinner now.
Okay, now there has to be the rocks here.
We just gotta find the other rocks.
Alright, where are the other rocks located then?
Hello, rocks.
Where are you?
Okay.
Guess we got more money.
What's the point of sitting this?
There's like literally nothing here.
There's just money.
Where the fuck?
Wait, there's no point.
There's just extra tickets.
I'm pretty sure.
How epic would you rate this?
game I mean it's pretty fun it's a platformer it's a good platformer more money for the mouse the mouse of house I missed that show that was such a good show I guess we got like the treasure chest but I feel like that was pointless that felt so pointless I'm still missing like Like,
one, two, three rocks.
How is there three more rocks around here?
I swear to God.
Yeah, that was a really, that was a good show.
They don't make those types of shows anymore.
It's like, they don't want to give Mickey Mouse a personality because he's supposed to be, like, a cookie cutter.
Like, he's just a mascot.
So, they don't give him any personality anymore.
I'm I'm about to give up I'm actually I'm just close to giving up
Oh my god I swear to god I feel like I've unpainted everything The newer Mickey Mouse shorts Were amazing I think I know what Mickey Mouse shorts you're talking about But I don't think you realize That was like What five plus years ago
They've ended that show.
They...
Yeah, quote-unquote, new way.
Yeah.
I feel like...
I'm never gonna find the last three stones, am I?
You check behind the big tickeys?
In the tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic-e-tic.
These guys?
Yeah.
I'm still missing one more.
I'm so... Where the fuck is this guy's last eye?
Where is his last eye?
Oh my god.
It doesn't matter.
I'm still missing one more rock.
I'm...
It doesn't even matter.
I'm still missing one more rock.
Wherever the fuck this last fucking rock.
rock is.
It doesn't matter.
I'm still missing one.
Wherever this fucking rock is.
Good job, Oh my god.
Where could this last rock be?
Doesn't even matter.
Where are you?
It's so fine.
Oh my god.
It's not in here.
Yeah, I checked them already.
The king paint.
Paints the rocks.
And yet, it didn't even matter.
Where the fuck is the last one?
Guys, someone...
Someone look up no commentary.
Epic Mickey Rebrush and help me find the last rock.
Where... I can't... I can't stay here.
We can't be here forever.
Look up.
Why look up?
Nothing above me.
I feel like I went through all of this.
What do you mean look up?
I've looked up.
Been here?
I've been here.
Look at this.
I painted that.
And then I painted that too.
You got that.
Wait, you saw it?
Where did you see it?
There's no way Where did you see it?
I passed it?
How?
There's no way you're fucking with me right now
It's a red rock It's right there, Toki.
No, there's no way You guys are actually fucking with me There's no way There's no way you guys There's no way you guys are fucking with me right now
It's not here.
How?
There's no way I passed it.
There's no fucking way I passed it.
You used to believe that.
I'm getting baited.
I...
I'm getting rage bait right here.
Oh my god.
I swear to God.
I feel like I've been here for 20 years.
In this one area.
In just this area.
area.
We're gonna spend our entire life in here.
If I was the last rock, where would I be?
Where the fuck would I be?
Oh my god, where is this?
Where is it?
I've unpainted everything!
What else can be unpainted?
Yeah, I- that was where the last one was.
I'm on the right track.
I've...
But how?
How am I on the right track?
I've been here for 20 years!
Why is this tree dead?
Oh my god.
I've been here.
Maybe it's under here.
No, it's not under here Maybe Maybe it's oh my god underwear where is the last rock?
Oh my god.
It was right.
It was right It was under here all alive.
It was under here all alive Aim thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Epic Mickey refresh.
All right location thank you it was a super chat thank you thank you it was here all a lot oh my god I swear to god if I just get a pin I swear to fucking god after I did all of this and it was just a goddamn pin I oh it's Daisy's arm okay at least that okay okay it was worth it I got her arm got your arm it was worth it guys Daisy needs that arm.
If she wants to...
Okay.
Don't say it, Turkey.
If she wants to...
If she wants to reunite with Donald, she needs that arm.
And Turkey.
Don't...
Why is there a bear down there?
In the Tiki Tiki.
Tiki, tiki, tiki, little in the Tiki, the Whalers.
Whoa, what's this?
Yes.
Yeah, to hold Donald's hand, guys.
Guys, to get to third base and hold his hand.
Exactly.
I don't know what else you guys were expecting.
Oh, nice.
Film.
That song is going to be stuck in my head for a while.
song, though.
And the tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki, tiki.
Ow.
I don't know what I expected.
Not gonna lie.
I don't know what I expect.
I don't know.
I thought it would boost me up like a little rocket jump.
Like, what was the point?
I feel like there's no point in getting these tickets.
Like, I'm fucking rich already.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, nice.
No secret.
Oh?
It doesn't matter.
Back here, you'll bird.
All birds are just government spies.
Made to surveillance, yo, because it's just cheaper.
It's just cheaper than paying Google for your data.
If you think about it.
Oh, shit.
That's not what I want to do.
Uh, okay, we gotta go this way.
Are you?
I'll never say.
Someone didn't read the terms of service.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You forgot my one-sixth and one-hour birthday, but now it's my one-sixth and two-hour birthday.
Uh, can I...
Sure, no problem.
Okay, happy birth.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got the Whalers.
Any Whalers in chat?
Oh my god, that's a giant-ass hole on that whale.
That's crazy that you can just kill it.
Look at that hole.
That's not natural.
That's not...
Wait, look at that hole.
That ain't natural.
There's something wrong with that whale.
it's like a oh my god it's monster monster oh i was gonna that was gonna go in yeah i won't go to tortuga bro cool thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
oh they help i wonder what well me taste like oh have you seen those videos of like whales that die on the beach and then they fucking just explode Looks like we need to find Baluga Billy to activate the projector screen.
Mickey, look!
Pirate's area!
Seems they've secured Tartuga!
You think they'll be friendly to us?
Yeah, because it's like the...
What was it?
The pressure?
The pressure of, like, the...
Because a whale's body isn't supposed to be...
Oh, because, like, apparently if you die, like...
If you leave the body out...
Uh, yeah, the, the, the gases, yeah.
If you die and, like, your body is just left out, the gases will make you just fucking explode.
It's like, kablooey.
Maybe this TV sketch will help you on your quest.
Enjoy.
What am I going to do with a TV sketch?
Hit this watch sketch, my friend.
Wait, who am I supposed to talk?
Oh, this guy?
I see you made it back from the jungle Maybe you can put it in good use Okay I can't wait to explode You should like Okay maybe I'm chaotic good But like At your funeral You should ask them to like Make sure Don't
Okay.
Jeez.
You feel a little surprised for your family and friends.
Whoa.
Tortuga.
While you continue on to skull a pilot.
Talk to Starkey before you leave.
Which one's Starkey?
Oh, listen.
Taking out the spider maintenance.
Wait.
The friends I made?
They killed my friends.
Oh.
That's true.
Put some comfort.
It'll be a little surprise.
The last surprise for your family and friends.
Like a little party popper.
One last surprise.
And push the beetle works down to the docks.
May you disintegrate yourself.
as someone to be reckoned with.
I'm making you an honorary pirate.
Don't ever see this coming.
Like, listen, any pirate will know you've earned it.
Yay, I got the pirate pin.
I'm an honorary pirate now.
You want to enter the pirate voyage?
Yay!
Wait, was there anything up here?
I knew it.
There's always like a secret in the back.
Oh, it was just $20.
I mean, that's a good secret, actually.
$20?
It'd be nice if I just, like, walk backwards and get a free 20.
Don't actually do that.
I think that might be traumatizing.
I don't know.
I feel like some of you of your family and friends might not like that if you just happen to explode confetti.
I didn't know what...
Not sure it is.
I mean, someone can test my theory up.
Oh, mate!
You think?
Alright, let's...
Alright.
Okay, I got it.
Do not try this at home.
Let's see.
Go this way.
Just don't use your corpse.
Maybe like...
I'm doing such a real...
Oh shit, I'm about to die.
That...
Like, in your will.
You're like, put in...
Put, like, a...
Use the body of a pig in my...
Uh...
Oh shit!
No!
Is it...
No, like, like, you know, a body of a pig in my...
What are they called?
The...
the casket and then it and then like put confetti in it and be like surprise that was a fake casket here's stopping from cooking it's like pinata yeah pinatas are fun for the whole family don't keep no my on my Mickey stream on my epic Mickey stream fuck this I don't need that $20.
That's so messed up.
I mean, it's better than using your own body.
Good luck.
Last surprise.
Okay, gotta grab this sketch.
I don't need that $20.
Do I can't give real life advice?
Oh wait, what's over there?
Wait, there's something over there.
Maybe it's something that's not $20.
But don't, but don't.
What's over here?
Oh, it's a film.
Nice.
Alright.
We gotta go back.
This is time to go to Tortuga!
Tortuga time!
Wait, this isn't Tortuga?
Why am I jailed?
I've committed no crime.
It's not a crime when it hasn't happened yet, guys.
You can't be like, yes, you did, Doki.
It isn't a crime if everything I say is just hypothetical.
Oh, I get jailed for a mere thought?
A lot of things happen.
You can't jail me when I'm just thinking about it.
Is it like a conspiracy?
I thought we live in a free country!
They're called thought crimes.
I still don't even see my room brew.
Three pumps installed along the river, but let me see one of them.
Whenever they are, I want to fill them all up to get the ride working properly.
Okay.
I did nothing It's not a crime
So then we get the red Working properly Okay why is this on fire?
I'm literally throwing paint on it Why isn't it working?
Okay Oh I just have to do this There you go I did it I fixed the world Oh there's Here Here Free country, she says.
Candace also free.
Our home and native land.
Cool patron up.
America's not the only free country.
Like, what do you mean?
You're like, she says this as she's Canadian.
Yes, because we also have laws.
We also have freedom of speech.
You're not the only country.
That has freedom, the speech!
You're-
That's fucking crazy.
Like...
God, that has laws.
What the fuck is our RCMP doing if we don't have laws?
You're right, nothing.
To be fair, RCMP does jack shit.
They just ride on their horses.
That's a good joke.
Let's see, we gotta go this way.
Can I?
Okay, I knew it.
All right, time to paint it.
She's shaming the Mounties.
I would say the Mounties is literally just the status symbol.
I don't think they had...
Do they actually do anything?
Okay.
One more, and I'll go.
Okay, we need one more.
So I'll make sure there's nothing fucking hiding under there.
Oh, it's over there.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Oh, shit!
Oh, no, this is bad.
Oh, my.
I can live.
Yeah.
Partnership beam.
No, we have our own FBI.
I don't remember what it's called, though.
That's his own name.
I also unpaint this and then the door I fucking knew it I've learned from last time you know this works all right how am I sure I there's no random daisy parts lying about I know we have the FBI like the Canadian version of the FBI but I don't remember what it's called why can they even still have the bounty police because it's just like it's just funny that they're riding their little horseies around it's like a little what's over here oh it's on fire why is it on fire what if i just paint it better wait how do i guys how do i get it not on fire that doesn't sound good Wait,
it's just on fire.
How do I...
How do I fix that?
Guys, that's what...
The pipe.
I just break it?
Yeah, but it doesn't unbain itself.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I didn't see the band-aid.
I could just blow on it.
RBI is the RCMP?
So you can take funny photos.
with the Mounties.
That's all I'm gonna say, like, that red is not camouflaging anything.
To be fair, the horse is not, and I think when you see a horse fucking coming at you, you know they're coming.
Am I missing anything?
No, right?
Because you don't know if I'm, like...
I don't know if I'm missing anything.
Because in the entire world, there's, like, secrets everywhere.
I don't think I am.
I'm gonna go straight here.
I'm gonna straight in.
I don't think I'm missing anything.
Oh, I got free the pirates!
Don't worry, I'm- I'm a hero!
What the fuck did I free?
Oh, I have to free all- oh, I have to do all of the levers.
Oh yeah, you're right, they're for the parades too.
All right, I freed all of you.
I'm a hero!
I don't know if I didn't give you this reward, but I'm supposed to free a fellow uh, Rigger Green.
He's laughing at Rome for treasure.
Maybe I'll share with you.
You see, I've been a trap to capture some of Hook's mechanical parts.
So a fellow Green stumbled into it.
That's where I'm headed.
When Hook's mechanical goon stuffed me in that cage.
Oh, there he is.
Now he's freed.
See, I'm lawful good.
This proves it.
How do I?
I forgot how to use the...
Oops.
That's not what I wanted to do.
How do I use my little blaster thing again?
Whoa!
Guys, do you guys remember how to use the blaster thing?
With the...
You see how I have three of these guys there?
How do I use it again?
I don't remember.
Wait, maybe I have my options.
Game setting.
Uh...
Where the fuck is the...
Where the fuck are the controllers?
I'm just...
Yeah, the...
Yeah, the blue lights thing.
I'm trying to figure out how to use the blue thingy.
Just steal yourself real fast.
Yeah, silver pin!
You see these little blue lights following me?
You're supposed to be able to use it, but I don't remember how to use it.
I just keep putting TVs down.
I'm on a controller.
Enjoy the loot.
I guess I'll do some boat hopping back once I get my sea legs back.
Pretty nice.
Why don't I open that door though?
Why is that door not opening?
Hello?
Just unpainted.
Oh, I just unpainted.
Okay, alright.
That doesn't seem very...
That doesn't seem like good security.
Oh, check input settings.
Where is the input?
Game settings.
There's no input settings, yeah?
What is my graphic?
Oh, it's epic.
There is?
Where is it?
Downward says...
Oh!
Oh, it's RB!
It's RB.
Friend.
There you go.
I'm a bit blind.
Just a little bit.
Okay, no one looks at the very bottom.
That's why nobody reads the terms of service.
Friend.
My friend attack.
Yeah.
Friend!
Okay, nice.
That's right.
I break in so I can force you to be my friend.
like all good friends do oh what's the point of forcing friendship on them all right and i'll go aggressive friending exactly they don't know that it's actually a good thing for them being my friend i wasn't yeah oh nothing what's going on what's going on Hey,
there's Pete!
Which way do I have to go?
That's the right way.
Oh, it's up.
The right way is always up.
Wait, is he a bad guy?
Oh, he was.
Wait, no, he didn't hurt me.
Oh, is this a shortcut?
I knew it.
I saw fireworks that I knew it was a shortcut.
Am I care enough to get the films?
I do.
Like, I'm like, I'm doing, like, things where I, like, it's, like, sort of a completionist, but, like, I, like, half-ass it.
It's not even, like, the full completionist.
I do, like, 50% of it.
I'm, like, that's good enough.
Like, I might as well not do it.
I'm like, you know, no, I made an attempt, you know?
I tried.
Like, 93% completion.
But I didn't have to get this.
Is there anything more?
Only completing half of it.
Look, at least I made an effort.
See, look, look at that.
Chang hide.
Okay, we go this way.
How do I...
This one?
No, that's not even part of it.
What the fuck?
What is that even for?
Oh my god I give up I'm fucking shortcut Shortcut
I can't even bother to parkour that I need my baby's first parkour clouds Alright nice I made it Yay Blue sky do Here I go I wanted to play Dora I want to play a Dora the Explorer game, but then they're all like I have to like get like an like what are they called?
I have to like emulate it because they're all like the CD-ROM games.
The boat bears a red flag and we can use it to reach hook.
That's it, but it looks like anchor lines are keeping it submerged.
We'll have to locate the anchors and cut them loose.
And then like, okay, I swear to God, like PC The PC emulation is so fucking confusing.
Because you have to, like, pretend you have to, like, fake your PC settings.
Into, like, as if it's, like, Windows XP or some shit.
And then I give up.
Hola, soy, yora.
The boat bears a red flag, and we can use it to reach hook.
That's it.
But looks like the anchor lines are keeping it submerged.
Okay.
Because I wanted to play the Blues Clues Birthday Treasure Hunt game.
Because that was a game I grew up with.
But then, like, every time I try to look up how to do it, I try to, like, look up how to do it.
Um...
Um, and it was, like, so difficult to try and get that to work.
I realized, like, a lot of PCs don't even have, like, disc...
Like, those, like, disc readers anymore.
You guys notice that?
Because everything is digital now.
We don't use CDs anymore.
Yeah, we don't like...
We don't put CDs in.
They all use digital or USB now.
So we don't have our cup holders anymore.
No, what's gonna hold my cups?
Wait, what?
How am I gonna hold my cup now?
Get naked.
Robot, man.
Whoa, Joki.
Why did you tell this robot to get naked?
Look, it's for his own good.
Get naked.
Taking off his gun.
Look at that.
Okay, there you go.
I got TV out of it.
It's time to strip that robot!
I think like each world is like takes longer and longer too.
Parsing machine reversing, you're on the right track.
Since you started with paint, you should use it on the rest as well.
See, I'm a good person.
I'm not destroying their land.
ship now we gotta make sure he oh shit my friend don't worry i'm stripping the robot
oh shit friend okay don't worry he's gonna put his clothes back on and then we'll take them off
there you go oh shit okay i didn't fully take it off that's my bad There we go.
Your friend.
Yeah, friendship.
This place is big.
It's a little confusing, to be fair.
Take it off!
I say that to all my friends.
Beware of the robot stripper!
Tokey, please.
Alright, let's get through this door.
Actually, what am I doing up here?
Oh, for this.
The fuck let me out!
There you go.
What am I doing up here?
What is up here?
The wheel.
What does that do, though?
Oh, hey, TV!
TV time.
Never mind.
Oh.
Where am I?
Like, what the fuck am I doing here?
Alright.
Like, what?
Whoops, sorry.
Oh, this way.
Oh, there it is.
Yay.
Wait, I didn't.
Darwin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's nothing to do with the stream, but I bought a dokeybird happy to go to the Ato concert.
Ato concert?
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
They're back to back?
One more paint and we'll start all those who are transformed by it.
And a concert is already passed.
Should I use it for...
Yeah, of course.
Of course.
You can wear it whenever you want.
Take it with you everywhere.
I'm glad they ride They ride pretty fast, though I didn't give them the super chat Oh my god, speaking of Ato Ato, how do you pronounce it?
Ato?
Or Ato?
There are red flags Of sneer around everyone?
Where the fuck is this red flag That they're talking about?
But like, I don't know if you guys remember this which one is the one that's not my friend try to figure out which one's not my friend is it the one where oh it's a no wait they're fighting each other wait how do i know if they're friend or not they're all blue
i don't pronounce eight odd um there was that there was this tweet from auto where um I don't remember which state it was, but like there was nothing there wasn't really anything exciting So she went to a grocery store and then took a picture of a cake at a grocery store I don't know if anyone saw that tweet There was like nothing There was nothing to tweet of there was nothing to tweet about That was fucking hilarious I mean,
there's the anchor right there.
How do I get there?
Wasn't New Jersey?
Because she was tweeting, like, tourist.
The funny thing was that for all the other states, she was tweeting, like, super touristy spots.
But it was...
It was literally, for some reason, that particular place.
She just...
She just didn't know, like, what the...
What the tweet about?
up all right friendship be friendship be be my friend you will like it and then there you go but that's my stay woo thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i mean she did like a world tour Not World Tour, but like a U.S.
tour.
Maybe it was a really good cake.
Guys, it was a grocery cake.
It was a really, really good cake.
To be fair, a lot of decorators, they just buy, they either buy grocery cakes or they use like, what's a cake mix.
And then they just decorate it really nice.
It's a little hack.
It's because you're really just...
You're really paying for, uh, um, a lot of, like, cake makers, like, cake decorators.
They were just, like, buy a grocery cake and decorate it.
Yeah, it's mainly just for the look.
Yeah, why don't we waste time?
Why do we waste time making a cake from scratch?
Also, like, wedding cakes in general are, like, mostly just cardboard.
about it.
It's literally like they look really big and tall but it's just one layer that you could cut.
That's right.
We ameka you.
You're gonna be less cool now.
Yeah, they use cardboard with frosting.
But why are they happy?
They were so cool before.
The machine is turning monsters back into pirates.
Hey, robots have rights that can't be made better with some paint oh yeah it's fondant and and um it's usually just fondant or wait what's over there oh it's the anchor it's usually just fondant and uh cardboard and then it's like one layer that's actual cake that you cut they would like mark the area where like,
oh, it's for the bride and the groom to cut it.
To be like, this is the real kick.
Remember to cut this part.
Doki takes away rights from mutants and animals elves, but gives rights um, okay, you cannot be defending elves right now.
If anybody is, like, extra racist, it's elves.
Like, there is no way you're defending elves.
All right, nice.
I mean, that's true.
She has a point.
Yeah, what's the point?
There's no fucking way you're defending elves.
When they hate everything but elves.
They even hate other elves.
Like, what the fuck are you?
They even hate other elves because they're not the right elf.
There's no way you're comparing me to an elf right now.
Go back to the north.
All right, that's another ear.
Get those knife ears out of here.
Menace, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No.
Alright, let's make sure he's my friend.
Here's a knife.
No, no, I'm different.
I'm a bird.
I'm Doki bird.
I'm not Doki elf.
And now we can go after me.
Go after Captain Hook.
And there's a guy right there.
He's just chilling there.
You see that guy there?
He's just fucking chilling there.
He's just stranded in the middle.
of nowhere what the fuck is he defending there's like nothing there buddy like is it worth killing those robots I don't even know what he's trying to defend
okay maybe there's something up here the stream is sponsored by Lord Goritos and he's Grimard I don't even know what I was supposed to do here
I think that's everything.
Alright, we gotta find the boat.
Wait, what's over here?
I'd say I don't mind having sawed these for hands.
Better than it hooked by far.
That's what I'm saying!
I always like be a non-Mekka.
Better.
Where the fuck are these these parts?
Like, I swear to God.
Did I got all of them?
her her feet and her torso where the fuck is her other foot it's like hiding somewhere
yeah we have one arm and one foot guys you guys know where her other body parts are gotta do this for donald guys
guys we're doing this for him I have no idea.
I might give up.
I have no idea where it is.
I don't think it's even worth it.
Wait, no, I have to unlock the good ending, apparently.
It's alright.
She has one arm and one foot.
That's good enough.
I don't know where it is.
Daisy, you tell me where it is, chat.
How the fuck am I supposed to know where it is?
I asked to be somewhere here, though, I assume, because it's that...
It's around the way...
Around here.
Oh, I haven't been here.
He's like, he's mad at me.
Guys, I worked so hard to try... Oh, okay, no, that's... That it.
To get the good ending.
We have to get the good ending at this point.
I could have killed all those civilians here, but I didn't.
I had self-restraint.
Wait, what the fuck?
What's he doing here?
Pete Penn?
Who must be the Mickey Mouse I've been hearing about?
Of course you know me.
I was created a challenge with Captain Hook.
Oh, there's our foot!
But Hook captured my sprite friend.
And we're gone, it can't fly.
That's why I'm trapped here.
He keeps the sprite tied to the mass of his ship just to Tommy.
If I don't wait for here, I'll be there in an instant to give hook the what for.
Wait, what?
What is a trap?
Where is it tied up on?
I don't see the spray.
What is he saying?
Wait.
Restore the pipes.
Whoops.
I hope this expired doesn't mean like I fucked up.
I hope it doesn't mean anything bad.
Uh, that should be okay, right?
So to summarize, Doki thinks all cows are the same, has a fetish of reverse mermaids, and hates elves.
Oh, gee, I'm so proud.
Thank you for the super chat.
Bacon, thank you, thank you.
Release that sprite from the mass.
What the fuck is he talking about?
Like, up here?
Is that it?
Over there?
No, that's just a pain.
Where the fuck is it?
I don't see anything other any other mass stuff.
Okay.
Yeah, but where do I release it?
Oh, it's a later level.
Okay.
I'm like, where the fuck is it?
Is that the good?
That I had to hook right here.
Okay.
It's fine.
Is it actually a later level?
Hi, I'm unemployed.
Should I work at McDonald's or Target?
I'd say...
I honestly say Target.
Just because, like...
Um...
Just because I feel like fast food customers...
Dealing with...
In fast food field...
Is, like, more pressure.
than dealing in.
No, actually, they're both bad, because one is retail.
The other is retail as well.
Retail is pretty bad.
Yeah, but I feel like food service is more hellish than retail.
And target customers are better.
Okay, but like, it depends.
Are you a cashier or like a stalker?
If you just, not the bad type of stalker.
I mean, like, you're stalking things, like, as in, like, you're putting things on shelves.
If you're putting things on shelves, you can avoid customers.
But if you're in the fast food industry, then you can't really avoid them.
Yeah, if you're just an inventory guy, like, it's not as bad.
Is this little fucking sprite thing like...
At the hook, not at this level?
Yeah, you can...
Yeah, but you can avoid them more.
Compared to, like, fast food.
Take control of this vessel.
Okay.
I'm painting.
Is it painted?
Oh, it's during the boss fight.
Okay.
Before I go, I actually need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
All right, I'm back.
Whoa!
The sensitivity is so high when we're on our mouths.
Oh, Johnny, Allen, Medi, Champion, Bite, Boer, Rice, Medi, Matthew, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, it's time.
You sure you want head to the Johnny Roger?
Yeah, I'm fucking sure.
I'm pretty sure I'm missing one daisy piece somewhere.
It's like somewhere in the world.
I don't fucking know.
I'm fucking, I swear to God.
If it makes me look up a guy, I swear to God.
Alright, let's see.
Yes, I'm ready to leave.
I'm literally missing, like, one of her hands.
Or was her torso?
Adventureland.
Why is Daisy...
Because Daisy's a robot, and they, like, took her apart.
We should probably board the Jolly Roger, Mickey.
Looks like Hook's not here.
Okay.
I wonder where those stairs lead.
Maybe it'll help you.
Oh, there's the sprite.
There it is.
Okay.
You either free the sprite.
Or find a way to defeat the hook outright.
Wait, is this the sprite like...
What the fuck is trying to eat me?
Oh, is it the crocodile?
Guys, is the...
Okay.
Is freeing the sprite?
Good?
Is it a good thing or a bad thing?
Before I do it, I need to know.
Is it good or bad?
Probably depends.
Is it good?
Is it a good thing to do?
Or the spirit.
Sorry.
Was it a spider spirit?
I don't fucking know.
I need to know the morality and ethics guys listen to your good heart it said there is like another way so I'm like am I doing a good thing or am I doing a bad this is not philosophy class there's only a right and wrong answer we're playing fucking epic Mickey not fucking looking at philosophy right now not this is a game for children where if that there's only a right and a wrong answer.
Let me evaluate the ethical implication.
You best not be planning on rescuing the sprite, lad.
It's morally great.
But what army matters?
Welcome aboard.
Finally a worthy opponent for the great captain hook.
Now remember, let's keep your arms and legs inside the ship at all costs.
Oh, he's just there's I hope you're geared up for this Because it's going to be Barrows Barrows Of fun
Where am I?
Why am I?
Oh, I was gonna say Oh, it's like, crap, but don't let the crocodile Near me I mean crocodile
What's this?
Wait, what is this?
Oh my god, give me a sec.
Let me steal your treasure real quick.
The mecha, mecha croc.
The what?
The crocodile?
I don't know what you guys thought I said.
I said the...
I said the crocodile, guys.
I don't know what you heard.
Okay, we'll save the sprite.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
We'll never go.
We gotta have a 10 year study on what it does.
It's down from me at rigging a boy.
Will anyone, will anyone do the study?
How do I get up?
What is he?
What am I supposed to do?
Get painted.
He's like, stop painting me!
Oh, there it is.
I didn't see that.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no.
There we go.
I didn't see that I needed to paint this.
Okay.
Oh, that's why I...
Oh, that's...
Ow.
Okay, it's just a slow adventure.
Whoa!
Stop!
What's he doing?
Oh, shit.
That's fucked up.
Do I paint the balls?
Is that what I do?
Oh, it is.
Stop!
It's not cool!
Okay.
This is why Shmi left you.
It's not cool, bro.
Okay, we gotta do this.
Okay, how do I...
I just unpaint that?
Oh, I do.
Alright, good ending!
I rescued this friend!
I did it!
Wait, he's just leaving.
Is he not going to help me?
She's going to find Pete Pan.
I knew y'all could save the sprite, Mickey.
Now return the favor by taking that scoundrel hook off your hands.
Get to the deck.
I'm going to need some room to battle this rust bucket.
It's a hook.
You want to pick on someone your own size for once?
what's this my old nemesis i thought i've seen the last of you boy have at you
oh my god it's pete pan captain and mecca hook he's got a knife i swear to god that was the bad thing to do i swear to fucking guy i i i swear to fucking god Oh my god.
This is where all the budget went into.
This intense anime fight.
There's the next rocket part in the chest.
Your paint or thinner capacity can change.
Can change based on how you deal with important characters.
And...
Yay!
Okay, okay, that's a good upgrade.
That's a good upgrade.
That's good.
That's good, guys.
We got the good one.
We got the good upgrade.
my seat wait what open oh there that's a good update or good upgrade
yay i got another space park yeah let's go all right there's a protracted stream let's get out of here wait where what do you mean there's a word that it just showed me like look there it is What do you mean?
I was looking at myself.
Oh, it's right there.
It's okay.
He's got this.
I believe in Pete Patton.
He doesn't need me.
He's got this.
Oh, apparently the last daisy part is here.
Wait, but I killed his boyfriend.
He fixed the machine.
Oh, that means it's safe.
for us to go home to Skull Island again.
How delightful.
With Pan back, the captain will be his jolly old self again.
And he'll be needing his loyal crew to go after that scurvy knave so we best head out.
I guess you'll be zipping right back to Mean Street to tell the tale of your Tartuga adventure, won't you?
Yay, I did it.
I'm a hero.
Before we go, I'd like you to have this.
I think it's... Oh, I did!
Oh, he had That's fucked.
Smeet, what were you doing with her torso?
Goodbye, but wait a minute, Smeet.
What were you doing with Daisy's torso, Smeet?
Huh?
Wait, they gentrified it.
Where are all the pie?
They took over the town.
They...
I...
Oh, Mickey, you brought all my parts.
Thank you.
We did it.
She has her body back.
A lady does like to look her best.
Thank you, Mickey.
Oh, my gosh.
She's so much taller than me.
Holy shit.
Wait, it's exposed.
I like how everything else is like...
Damn, Oswald's freaky.
Don't you...
Where are you looking?
All I have to say is that Oz was Freaky Moon.
Any like hidden quest here?
We haven't painted all the bushes and trees yet.
What the fuck do you want?
So demanding.
He wants me to paint all the trees and bushes?
Alright.
I mean, this better get me a goddamn spark.
Oh, it seems they'll be taking me out to get my legs working again.
Jibia didn't bring my scrapbook for me.
I'm pretty sure I left it behind while I was visiting a train station on Mean Street.
Should I ask Pete where it might be?
Okay, so I asked Pete about that.
I mean, more sparks to get.
But I grab more sparks anyway.
We get those pies out of our hair.
Oh my god, excuse me?
Ricky?
You're just as brave as I've been hearing.
Anybody help me, those goddamn pirates.
Didn't they live here at first?
Now that he is gone, I'm Mr. Damien, so perhaps he could bring me some ice cream.
But sweet taste brings me back memories of my Damien.
Oh, I have an ice cream.
I can't eat much, but each taste brings back sweet.
memories okay I got the ice cream pin I can't believe it because the ice cream came from a pirate she didn't want it but because now the ice cream came from me she was like okay yeah how am I worse than these people guys how am I worse than these people here.
That paint everything?
Wait, have I not?
Oh, wait.
There's one bush right here.
Wait, what?
What other bush am I missing?
Oh, right here.
Oh, my God.
Every single bush?
This guy's crazy.
Come on, there's one over here.
Ow.
How did all of these bushes get unpainted anyway?
Like, who unpainted all of them?
Oh my god, there's some behind me.
And there's no counter.
I don't even know if I, like, if I'm getting close to finishing it.
I just have to assume that...
I just have to assume that, like, I'm missing a lot.
It doesn't even tell me.
I better get, I swear to God, if he only gives me a pin, I better get my goddamn spark energy.
Oh my god, what are the hitboxes for this?
Yeah.
I got these guys done.
Is there any more?
What's she doing up here?
Hi!
Oh!
for something a little different?
It's definitely one of my favorites.
Oh, no.
No, thank you.
No racing here.
I'm retired.
Is there any more bushes?
That I haven't cleaned yet?
Or, like, I haven't, uh, painted?
Is that it?
Padding all the plants.
Lovely work.
Please take this fire spark and eat tickets.
my compliments check back later and i may have another task for you oh thank god i needed that power spark i only did it for that all right what requests do i have to do daisy wants you find the missing pirate uh okay that's fine skipping that here's my ten dollars yeah we are not racing
all right back here bunny children Wait.
Wait, that means...
Oh, he's not sucking it up.
It's not for Pete.
So I'm not doing a bad thing.
Bunny, children, and sparks.
Yeah, okay, it's not bad now.
Guys, it's not for Pete.
Now I can...
Now I can kidnap the kids.
There we go.
One.
But I did it.
Oh my god, don't get away from me!
Get out of here, children.
okay nice i got all the i did it oh my god get out of here children get out of here don't touch me
children you're getting wise and hiding tribe bust they like using him at high wait i keep that getting locked at all times and i'll even clear the way for you to get it but it's for the lady i see wait how do i get the now folks you see how truly i truly am ain't nobody gonna be questioning it i'll be known as pete the grave i suppose you want something for your efforts i got too many of them anyway it's just pocket change and take a pirate spark too they're taking up too much space is everything miss well i got just a thing having multiple pete's running wasteland is swell not but what about the pete's from the past just going around about some old cartoon clips and the great colonel pete so you're gonna by Lonesome Manor.
Find those clips for me, huh?
And hey, small fry.
We're going to come back through Bog Easy.
Try not to drop the cartoon in the thinner.
So you may Pete Tronic.
I have so many quests from Pete.
Now two of us, Pete's is smart.
Things are looking up.
Of course, having another Pete should be rewarded enough.
But I suppose you can take a power spark.
Come see me again.
I have another thing.
Okay.
As long as the children don't get kidnapped by Big Bad Pete, we should be fine.
I heard, like, doing the Oh my god.
I swear to God.
Don't get near me.
I am this close.
I'm this close to...
Oh!
Don't make me do it!
Children!
You know I will.
I'm this close to me.
Jailing you.
Alright, we got another pin.
There ain't no way.
I'll turn you over to P. I swear to God.
It's that easy.
It's like near it.
So where the fuck is it?
It should be like hidden behind the area, I assume.
What the fuck is her goddamn photo album?
It's not here.
Not here.
here I'll grab this pin yeah got the glove pin okay where did these children come from how did you get here oh my god how did these kids get here get out of here children wait where's the Oh, it's in this gate.
Okay.
There it is.
There's your folder album.
Oh my god, please.
Get away from me, kids.
Me, when I see children.
Whoops.
Sorry.
I wanted to pawn the kids off of him.
This one is in search through the round.
A mask has been reported stolen from there.
Can you go in over there and investigate it?
I just got my big Achilles yet.
It's an unsolved mystery.
Constant Hatchaway was once the lady of Lonesome Matter.
Several of her husband expires.
There are suspicions, but no evidence.
Miss Hatchaway hid a hatch in the house.
It is evidence I need.
If you can locate it, the find would be huge for my detective agency.
You can reach Lonesome Matter by going through Boggyzi.
There's a projector screen at the end of the street that goes there.
Oh my god, we're gonna find a murderer?
weapon.
I'll let Moody tell Moody as soon as I can.
Rumors travel fast here, so I'll bet he knows.
But another solved case, I'm sure married business will roll in.
I'll add it all to you, Mickey.
Here's a power spark for the trouble.
Stop by in a bit, and I'll tell you about another case I'm working on.
Okay, is that all the cases?
Okay, the Tiki mask.
Alright, we'll have to go back anyway, so...
Alright, let's go back.
Yeah, that's why his name is Horace.
Okay, that's the last world I need to unlock.
But...
Ten tickets, please.
What is bad about kids?
Kids are very cruel, because they haven't developed a morality compass yet.
Wait, there's footsteps here.
So they don't know what's right or wrong.
So they're like...
So they're, like, particularly more evil than the other age.
Oh goodness, did you just come from the Tiki hut?
I was just over the trial and mass.
But I guess I did give it to Tiki Sam to sell it.
I have no right to change our agreement.
Oh, he was the one that stole it.
They do, yeah, they do things because they think it's fun, and they don't know it's wrong.
And they're very easily moldable.
Wait, I gave you the mask.
This is not your mask.
what do i give it to horace all right let's give this to daisy real quick yeah they're very like easy to influence i have to treasure this scrapbook there's a special guest sketch i had in here forever and i like you to have it i wanted my power sparks i don't need money in game in game in game
i think kids
Kids can say the wildest things in video games.
Because they have no filter, and they don't know, like, what's right or wrong yet.
Nice.
Is that everything?
All the quests?
Okay.
Locate the vintage cartoon and collect film reels for the...
Oh, wait.
Did I collect all of it?
Okay, I gotta go talk to the usher.
Alright.
Yay!
I have a power spark.
Okay, that should be enough, right?
I'm gonna need 15 power sparks before I can open the projector screen.
I found a stash of power sparks while you're away.
But three children have eaten them.
You should try to get the power sparks back before from them.
I did.
Didn't I literally just do that?
Oh, there you go.
Now I fixed it.
Just press this button, pull this lever.
Projector screen to bog easy.
Have a safe trip, Mickey.
Oh.
Alright.
I think this...
Is that the last load?
That should be the last level, right?
Are we close?
Okay, but it took me like three hours to complete the other level.
Alright.
Oh, it's the ghost short!
I love this one!
It tells about how poor they are, and they have to cut the fucking bean.
Bean lover!
Is this the bean lover?
That one!
It's too real.
The air sandwich, yeah!
Or was it bread?
Sorry, it was bread or bean.
I don't remember.
Is I a bread or bean?
There's my $20.
I like that one.
That one was one of my favorite cartoon shorts.
Can I jump?
Yeah, I can.
Whoa, what is that?
Was that good good ghost?
Oh my god, it's a good good ghost!
Okay.
Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
Oh, I can't- Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
Ow.
That's fucked up.
Wait, what do I do?
It's this way.
Wait, this one is more confusing than the other ones.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my god, are you serious?
Okay.
Go this way.
I had to look away.
It was...
It was so scary.
Okay, I had to go this way.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
And then I go up.
This one's a little more confusing than the others.
Oh, that has to be the developer's faces.
Where are the...
Where are the fucking films?
This way?
Did I got hurt by a chair?
Oh, it's a scary chair.
Okay, Doki, don't understand.
That's a spooky chair.
I was like, what the fuck did a chair hurt me?
Like, what hurt me there?
wait where were any of the films i didn't find any films there what the fuck i'm so spooked right now i give up we don't need to find film reels the threat of splinters is no laughing matter serious.
It's a very uncomfortable chair.
It was a gamer chair, Doki.
Oh, hey, Gilbert.
Looks like we got live one.
Come on, guys.
Watch out.
The ghosts are here, and we're ready to scare.
Say, Mickey, you look like the kind of guy who likes a good scare.
I hear that you aim to get to the load in some matter.
It just so happens that I can open the game.
If you help me out with some scary and some locals, I'll open that bad thing?
Guys, is scaring locals a bad or a good thing?
Wait, that seems like a bad thing to do.
Did they consent to getting scared?
Mr. Ghost?
Oh, hey, there's a bad.
It's just a purple heart.
We're lost.
This is probably very scared with all the ghosts about.
Perhaps we can locate the owner.
Yeah, I was like, whoa.
Guys, look at that.
I got a purple heart.
What's that?
Uh, crime where you impersonate a soldier?
Is that my butt?
Stolen valor?
It's your lucky day, Mickey.
I have a special offer for you.
You just pick up that courage medal from the ship, right?
if lewis gets his hands on it we won't be able to have fun scaring him anymore i can make sure he gets taken somewhere else okay yeah i think that's a it's your loss but don't expect me to do you any favors from now on
like i'm not supposed to give that to him right
wait was that good or a oh my god maybe this is philosophy Thank you for your service, Toki.
Patra has to thank you with a super chat.
Wait.
Wait, it was...
I don't understand.
Am I scaring bad people?
Okay, but like...
Maybe the guy was a really bad person.
That's why.
That's why he's getting scared.
He's getting spooked on right now.
He could be a really bad person.
You don't know his history.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
chat thank you thank you i give you the very fast go crazy sergeant dokey thank you for the super chat many thank you thank you i don't know i i don't know am i am i supposed to give him the meta
there it is boggy z square those gates oh there's donald those gates back here leads to Lonesome matter.
What a lonely shack.
We should ask around to find out how the locals know anything.
Okay, guys, guys.
Wait, what the fuck?
I erased her.
Got your face!
Okay, guys.
Was me not giving the ghost the meta a good or bad thing?
This is not... There's no morality question.
I need to know I'm questioning my ethics and morality right now Was it a good or bad thing that I I didn't give him the the meta One of books has escaped from Madame Leona's library in those some manner She gets really angry when her collection is disturbed and she's blaming me Can you catch it for me if she doesn't get it back?
I'm in serious trouble
If it's not recovered, I'll never let live it down.
Okay, I gotta find the book.
Remember that guy who directed Epic Mickey also directed Desil X?
USX Machina?
Expect some deep philosophical ethical questions.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, it's a power spark.
That looks like a power spark.
Oh, hey, there's another lantern.
Oh, my God.
It's another goddamn lantern shit.
life in bog easy has come to halt because of the ghost they move from lonesome matter down here but no one really knows why don't scare me so much but the boys seem paralyzed with fear bertrand is here in the square louis lives in an old shack in the swamp if only there was a way to restore their courage can you help i'll gladly open the gate for you that leads to the mansion yeah i can sense some of the blot in you but i also sense a good heart oh okay okay It was a good thing.
Okay, okay.
It's a good thing.
Oh, there's Donald.
A mad doctor of Betoworks busted you up.
Whack, those...
You want me to find the rest of your parts, right?
Just tell me where they are.
Dread it, ghost, haunted, bat rid and tumble down.
Lonesome matter.
Got it.
See you later, Donald.
Ah!
Body and abyssus.
But what's really bad is, those ghosts went and hid them in a lonesome manner.
No good.
Crazy ghost.
Quit showing off with your arms and legs and help me.
Okay.
We'll give a lantern here.
You know what's funny?
Goofy is the only one out of three that actually has kids.
Or has a child.
Um.
Okay, we gotta give...
Go to the...
Louis.
Okay, let's light this up real fast.
Goofy fucks.
Time to finally scare you, so I want to help me out.
Just put out all the lights, and I'll take care of the rest.
He's especially easy to scare right now because we took his courage medal, which always made him feel better.
I bet we could give him a good scare.
He's thinning out the lamps outside of his cabin.
This is a perfect chance.
Let's not waste it.
Meet me over by the cabin.
That's not fair!
The evil quests are so I oh my god If I get to be evil I can scare a better Sorry, I don't think I I'm not gonna I I'm not gonna repeat that I It's not fair.
I can't give him PTSD Because I have to be good
It's so you It's so easy.
Not fair.
But I know.
I have his purple heart.
Don't worry.
Yeah.
Good person by the way.
I'm not doing it.
I thought about it.
But look.
See look.
You found my badge.
I always feel more afraid when I carry that around.
Hey, can I...
No.
I have a choice.
It's like, yes or no.
All right.
Here you go.
If you ever want your health refilled, just come visit my shack.
No.
It's such a good person in theory.
Doing the right thing is so hard.
What the fuck is that?
Porch showed an increase in mechanical pirates in Tartuga area.
Intrusive thoughts.
Wow, it looks like when I spawn this courage, I won't be able to scare him now.
It costs nothing to be kind.
But Toki, you get to have the sense of doing a good thing.
because you did a good thing.
It's not funny.
It costs, yeah, it costs nothing to be evil, too.
Not fair.
All right.
Funny, good, evil.
All right, I did a good thing.
Can't judge me no more.
Because I did a good thing.
Living so near no lonesome matter can be trying sometimes.
Oh.
Materi thinks I'm a scary tack, does she?
Oh, Troufis, I would feel better if all the lamps around here were lit.
The ghost put out all the eight light of the lamps I saw.
Do you think you could relit them for me?
I would really appreciate it you're such a bitch i bet you sleep with a nightlight on too aren't you little boy little bitch boy all right i'm missing two more lanterns all right one over here hey mickey wondering why all the ghosts are hanging around this dumb the pipe organ lonesome matter has gotten mad and is driving all of us crazy can you fix it these folks are no fun and we want to go home if the organ is any matter we'll never be able to leave here okay that's how you fix it give grandpa an all-expense paid vacation thank you thank you okay there you go now he's not scared anymore guys so that i did i did the right thing see Sometimes I can do the right thing,
guys.
Wait, what's she doing here?
You aren't afraid of anything.
That's right.
I'm spectacular.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
I gotta break this.
Alright.
Alright, here you go.
Oh, I see you're lit them.
Thank you so much, Mickey.
You're any panther?
Come see me.
Okay.
Nice.
You're done right by both Veteran and Lewis.
You're a hero here.
I'm sure Materi would open the gate to Lonesome Matter for you now.
Okay, nice.
I got my stuff refilled.
How brave are you to help those poor guys?
Please accept the gold pin as a token of my appreciation.
I'll open the gate to Lonesome Matter for you.
It can help those two guys then get all of us.
Yay, I did it.
I'm a hero.
All right, time to fix Donald.
of need we're not able to okay we don't need that uh pipe organ okay hand two feet and his torso okay and then we gotta find the murder weapon holy shit how much is this how many acts how many people did she fucking kill okay we gotta find the murder weapon too and Enter Lonesome Manor,
visit, buy, and locate the vintage cartoon.
I'm a hero.
Yes, I do.
The toughest job out there.
Turning on the lamp.
That's right.
Oh, if you turn on the lamps, they die.
Cool.
Whoa!
Alright, time.
What does this do?
Oh nice, there's a film reel.
I actually need that.
Alright.
You don't understand, guys.
Someone has to turn on that lamp.
Someone had to do the tough jobs around here.
Come on.
This is the slowest spooky pot.
The slowest of them all.
Get me out of here.
Alright.
Make that book fly!
Okay, but wait for me.
Okay, book.
Hello, Mr. Book?
Mr. Book!
You're right, the light hurts the gamers.
Nice.
Okay, goodbye, ghost.
Alright, goodbye, girl.
Yay!
Okay.
Turn off this light.
Bye.
Okay, I knew there was a film reel back there.
From, like, zero film reels to, like, two.
Lonesome Manor Time!
Of course, light mode gets rid of the gamers.
I think we go outside?
Look what happened to me when I went outside.
Almost...
I almost actually went through two two events that I know that some people don't even experience once a lot happened I went through a volcanic eruption and the was it the most rain ever recorded in Hong Kong two very funny if I don't definitely not as funny when you when you're there
Spooky!
Spooky, scary skeletons.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Spooky.
You know what I mean?
I want to change clothes.
Wait, no.
What was that?
I don't like the football one.
I have to find these.
Alright, let's be regular Mickey now.
I'm done being a steam...
I'm done being in public domain, Mickey.
The symbol again just scrolls through the graveyard.
So simple!
Now it's in here.
When Mr. Jerome left to the USA...
Wait, he left...
He, like, went to America and then they gave him a grave?
The master jokes even up there, she's still roasting folks.
That's fucked up.
He traveled to the States and they just enacted a grave for him.
Old Uncle Hoffman built his own coffin in which he could lay.
Couldn't afford a wood, so he made it out of clay.
That's not so bad.
Rest in peace, Charles.
She fell from Kilimanjaro.
was changing in light when he had a shocking idea.
Rest in peace, dear Uncle Nate, who would have foreseen your twisted fate?
Oh wait.
Rolf was once here, but is no more the long arm of the law, even the score.
Oh, he's a criminal.
That is so bad.
Hey, what's the point of restoring their graves?
Anyway.
There's no point in doing that.
Just give me little funny stories.
Yeah, what the fuck was the point?
To honor the dead, Doki.
What's the point if I can't get anything out of it?
Here is Timo.
Work to the core.
Now he's using.
Can't take no more.
Those islands rise up from...
Must be part of...
At least it'll help you get across.
Oh, okay.
I just put a T.
on here.
TV tab.
Yes, with the TV.
There we go.
I got the TV up.
Okay, now they're my friends.
What's over here?
Oh, there's more graves.
The tombstones were sell.
Please contact Gremlin Maxim if interested.
How can we link this to Kingdom Hearts?
Hey, they didn't announce Silk Song yet.
At Gamescom?
No, right?
It still doesn't exist, right?
Cousin Ethan enjoys his papers.
Pulled one too many and made the papers.
Wait, they actually announced Silk Song?
Wait, okay, kind of?
Okay, was it what?
Three seconds?
They announced an announcement for...
Thursday.
It was the first thing they showed.
There's an announcement in 24 hours.
Oh, so it was 3 seconds.
Cousin Alex lies beneath a 15 seconds, actually.
The spectra behind him made no sound.
Mr. Jones, master of the chase, collecting the reaper, but lost the race.
I can't believe it.
They've done it.
They finally did it.
They've announced 6 Silk Song.
They even announce it and oh I'm stuck hello oh my god okay I'm back they've actually I can't believe it they finally did it they've announced an announcement the brother j builders renowned built the graveyard where they lay in the ground I wish they like never announced it
just done that instead of putting to tv sent dear aunt wendy over the edge because it's just funnier where we just keep waiting uncle joe thought he was a bird took a step off the ledge and it's now what and is now interred
it's like schrodinger's cat and then instead of cat is silk saw
Whoa!
Why the fuck did that rock got blasted out?
Oh, it's the mad doctor.
I've heard about you stumbling about in wasteland.
You're wrecked the day you found me, Mickey Mouse.
Because as far as you'll get, my defense will keep you out.
It's both in a released and unreleased state.
It looks like he left something behind.
What do you think it is?
Okay, if they announce Silk Song tomorrow or release date, I'll play Hollow Knight.
We'll just lay the rest here, Armin.
Who picked a fight with too many bars?
A brush in hand rests Aunt Jenny.
Finally, her art worth more than a penny.
Oh, okay.
Where's the lookout?
Oh, shit.
It's a little too late.
Wait.
For Nick, the brick fell too quick.
What will make this?
Wait, but where is...
Where the fuck is the thing?
Where the fuck is my anvil?
How am I supposed to...
Ah, fuck this.
An anvil maybe?
I don't need an anvil for this.
I can just put a TV.
Okay, apparently not.
It's not strong enough.
At least I can go up the stairs.
Okay, the anvil has to be up here somewhere.
Spooky.
Where the fuck is the anvil?
Oh shit, hello.
Hello.
There we go.
Get out of here.
That's Badouche had me trapped in here.
I was sure I was a goner.
Here, take this Anvil sketch.
Oh, I can just summon an Anvil now.
Well, this is a weight off my mind.
You found an Anvil sketch.
How many times I said that to yourself?
What I could do right now with even one Anvil.
Remove opponents.
Trigger pressure plates.
Climb.
Oh my god, I can use this as a platform.
Wait, that's nice.
My own platform.
Okay, and then press LB.
All right.
The sketches at least don't weigh anything.
The anvil's.
Oh!
Yay!
Okay.
Oh, and I locked it, too.
All right.
Nice.
I have the anvil and...
I bet he was taking that chest with him when we hadn't scared him off.
Scared who off?
Who the fuck did I scare?
I didn't there was nobody here oh no my little guy my little gremlin is a little schizo I was like there's no one here who do I scare who am I scaring up
all right oh whoops friendship is magic okay and then we just kill him there you go that's fine I can tank a little all right is there anything back yeah what's back here your last tattoo not hit by one bus oh my god he got double Isakai someone really didn't like that man I
can fix it right
it's like the unnamed soldier guys it's a we'll never know he was he wasn't he was just buried Randomly, guys.
The unnamed soldier, everyone.
The unnamed...
I can't believe they didn't give him a tombstone, guys.
That's so fucked up.
That they forgot in the history.
Oh, man, guys.
That's so messed up, guys.
I can't believe they didn't give him a gravestone.
I can't believe they did.
that guy that's so messed up it was like this when i got here guys what was the point of painting all these tombstones earlier
all right there you go
nice i kept it open for good guys see Good person.
Oh, wait.
Why was there a pirate here?
Can I...
Ow!
Tarni and ghosts aren't really ghosts.
They were never alive, so to speak.
What the fuck?
Madam Leona is feared by many, but she kind to those who help her.
Am I supposed to kill them?
Or, like, let them chill?
I just locked them up.
There you go.
There we go.
I'll just get back into your prison, I guess.
Are you ready to enter the Lonesome Manor?
Yeah.
Sealed the way.
Out of sight, out of mind, exactly.
It's like he was never there.
It's a time thing.
There's something's over here, though.
Oh, is it filmed?
Oh, I knew it.
I knew there was a film reel.
Never mind.
It was just more money.
It was just $5.
That's it.
Seals you in the wall.
Don't make me angry.
Okay, oh, there's the film reel.
What the fuck?
Wait, why didn't that...
Oh, that was weird.
Alright, nice.
Got the film real.
Oh, this is a mad doctor cartoon.
We're actually in the mad doctors there.
Wait, what's over here?
I mean, I don't need $20 right now.
Okay, there's ice there.
There must be a film up top.
Ooh, spooky spider.
And then there's a...
What is this open?
I knew it.
Yay!
Yeah, I'm sure.
I'm ready to enter.
Don'ts a matter.
There's a scooter.
Looks like a lot of poltergeists are loose in here.
Oh.
including a ghost trapped in that bottle poor guy really wants out okay help the ghost in the foyer all right there's the splatter people the mad dog wasn't kidding when he said he had set up defenses that looks like the way to go how do we get there and open it up oh it's Fantasia Fantasia man okay okay Just slowly.
Make them all good people.
It's not brainwashing.
Guys, it's not brainwashing.
They all wanted to be good anyway.
What's the point of being here?
Wait, what?
What was the point of being here?
Oh, I can use them as platforms.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Wait.
Wait, what is the point of...
Oh!
Oh, there was...
There was stuff here.
Okay.
Like...
Okay, I can't do anything here.
Is there anything in here?
Film reel.
Oh, it's Colonel Pete's film reel!
We needed that.
Okay.
But...
Good.
The power of good.
Okay, and then we gotta get rid of him.
There we go.
Okay, what does this do?
Okay, we gotta grab some money real quick too.
We gotta rob these guys a little, but it's okay, they're good now.
They let me rob them.
They consented.
And we'll paint this so I can use it as a platform.
the power good nice keep painting yes oh my god what the fuck okay okay that spooked me a little bit I was like what was he doing uh I have to unpaint that
uh spooky door what's over there though Let's get it.
The power good!
How compelled you!
Anything back here?
No.
Had to go this way.
How do I get...
How do I get that platform with me?
Power Pink compels you!
I gotta make sure, like, he doesn't go crazy on me.
How do I get up that?
Get up from there.
Oh, he's over there.
They're locked up.
Oh, okay, there you go.
I thought it doesn't go to me.
I reached this.
I'm going to snipe him.
There you go.
Yay!
Don't worry, I'm here!
Thank you, sir.
I assume you're here full of the plans of the mad doctor.
I shall help.
I'll open the way for a brief moment.
A moment is all I can do.
Wait.
How fast is the moment?
though.
Oh, it's timed.
Okay, it's timed.
Okay, okay, before I go there, though, I need to go this way.
I'm gonna steal some money real quick.
Where the fuck is Donald Duck's parts, though?
Is it back here?
Okay, oh, okay.
We're gonna have to put the anvil in.
Get out of here.
Alright.
I need to put my anvil.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, my God.
I can't multitask.
All right.
Oh, is anyone there?
I can't stay outside this bottle.
Is that Gilbert?
The mad doctor heard two of his servants flank the door to open the cell.
That opened it, and then he stuck me in this bottle to put it in here.
Oh.
Did I not do it?
My anvil?
How the fuck?
Oh, I can unpaint it.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's messed up.
They broke my anvil.
How are they that strong?
Holy shit, they're tanky as fuck.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's only one at a time.
I'm a little stupid.
hello sir get me out of here please i forgot it's only one at a time oh i thought i killed it i i was like i was like oh my god did i kill him did i put him in special hell and just exploded i can breathe again that's just the figure speech you see here i don't really need oxygen oh aren't you mickey mouse how long was i in the bottle well mickey i let me show be a little secret i learned in my time here i i i actually thought i i killed him that would otherwise cause these skulls house that otherwise cause chaos here the spirits in them are only pacified when the skull is fully restored okay is it a good thing to paint them in i i uh let me read this real quick oh my god
Okay.
I hope...
Is it...
It's...
It's good, right?
Like...
Would they be a good ghost?
That's one skull.
The spirits are free.
Let's find the other skull.
Okay.
all right it's over on the other side i legitimately thought like i wasn't supposed to like like he just exploded into money and i was like oh no like am i a murderer no he's already dead technically i i'm not a murderer i did it come talk to me all right time to talk to screeching sam Where the fuck are the Donald parts?
Does he have a Donald part?
Good show.
Thanks for all the help.
Here's the way out.
Gotta take out, but here have my treasure.
You've earned it.
Yay.
What's in it?
Oh, it's a pen.
Yay.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, wait, that's where he was in.
Okay.
Oh, they made him good.
Okay, that's good.
Alright.
I just want to make sure that...
Wait, did I go up there yet, guys?
I did.
That's when I saved the man.
The gremlin.
The man.
I guess there's no dog.
no part here, I assume.
Yeah, I'm ready to go to the stretching room.
Alright, let's go to the stretching room.
There's nothing here.
Wait.
I knew it.
I knew this was a platform.
Alright, I could tell.
The what room?
What is the stretching room?
All right, off we go.
Okay, this way.
Oh my god, there's the evil tree.
Oh my god, and the evil house behind me.
You can tell it's extra evil.
Okay.
Anything down here?
Wait, what's the point of going up?
Yeah.
The bats don't even hurt me.
The spiders do.
Whoa.
Oh, it was just...
It was just a shadow.
Up I go.
Yay!
$20.
God, I'm so rich right now.
Of all the $20 in the world.
And...
I'm risking it.
Fuck!
Okay, it's fine.
We don't need it.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
He's coming after me.
There's no way.
he goes through that that's right it's a gap in the hole what you gonna do about that
is one weakness a hole can actual creep oh my god it's a creep oh wait how do i jump over that oh there you go you have to wait the last second is one weakness
Wait, there was nothing here.
Huh.
I would assume there'd be one more film.
There it is.
And I'll go.
No way we share this.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's the murderer!
That's her!
That's the...
The Black Widow.
Money.
Alright.
gave it and these are all the husbands she's killed oh no that's a puzzle oh my god in their underwear
these paintings are the guardians of this place we can only proceed through this room with their blessing don't worry they'll let us through I go way back with them oh what Am I just supposed to...
Oh, I'm supposed to remember.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm supposed to remember.
Spin into...
And got to match them all.
Oh, that's easy.
It's not too hard.
I remembered it.
Okay, but what's over here, though?
Anything, like, interesting in here?
Wait, can I un-paint this?
Oh, I can!
Master Gear will activate them.
But what's in here, though?
Oh!
I knew it.
You know that Gaben retired?
Like, he's, like, semi-retired, right?
He lives on a boat now.
In the sea.
He's a boatman now.
Okay, so I can unpaint these.
Okay.
Yeah, he's just vibing in the sea right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, he's...
literally uh he's one with this he's one with the boat there's nothing in here okay what about here
i wonder if like i wonder if like each turn gives me like a different place
Let's find out.
Does it change, like...
No, it doesn't.
Alright.
Okay, let's match all of them now then.
Um, there's his pants.
And then...
Oh, okay.
Um, that's not how it should look like.
Um...
That's awesome.
Now how it should look like as well.
Um, okay.
And then we twist it.
Oh, this is...
This is a lot more confusing than I thought.
Wait, guys.
Oh, okay.
I figured it out.
Okay, and then...
Okay.
I figured it out.
Oh no, the puzzle has a puzzle.
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
I'm so smart.
Hurry up.
And then that's not the head.
And then there's the head.
We did it!
Yay!
Wait, one of the paintings?
Which one?
Which one did I do?
Oh, wait.
That's fine.
I just fixed it like that.
There you go.
I want to check something.
Oh, oh!
I knew it!
Each room!
Oh my god, Dono might be in here.
I knew it.
Oh my gosh, I'm so smart.
This is the room I fixed, by the way.
Okay.
I had a feeling.
Dono might be in here this time.
Oops.
Nope.
Is Donald in here?
Okay, he's not in here.
How about in here?
Donald, are you in here?
Buddy!
Buddy, where are you?
Okay, not here.
Wait, that means, like, the second step.
Okay.
Okay, this...
is oh okay um wait i want to see if there's anything in here it could be in here okay no empty you don't know that they could have hide his hide his arm in here oh thank you for the super chat thank you thank oh i knew it i knew it okay that's not donald but it's somebody thank you mickey i'll restore these paintings for you i'm quite an artist myself Oh,
he'll do it for me.
Okay, to win!
First Thelanus, as originally intended.
Yay!
I don't have to try!
Restore the classic Renaissance triangle composition.
Wait, I fixed this.
Oh my god, he ruined it so he could fix it himself.
Okay.
Excellent.
All paintings are lined up.
Just hit the gear in the middle of the room again.
All right, cool.
Wait, where the fuck am I?
Wait, where did he put me in?
What the fuck?
I had to find... I was trying to find Donald!
I did it.
I outsourced.
I outsourced it.
Once you're all the machinery started up, the paintings opened the door for us.
I told you we went way back.
Look, guys, I outsourced it.
I outsourced the work for cheap.
Yay!
Cheap labor, though.
Yippee!
Is he evil or is he good?
Wait, I can't even go through it!
What if Donald was in there?
Oh my god, I can't even go.
go through it.
Okay, maybe Donald wasn't in there, guys.
Maybe it wasn't.
Maybe he's okay.
Yeah, I'm ready to go to the library.
Where the fuck are his parts?
Like, actually, where the fuck is it?
Yeah.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, yeah.
wait there's like a switch here turn it off and then there's no fire oh my god really welcome to science
we'll do first this for the film all right down we go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa don't ground me up
where the fuck are down in those parts Was a chicken plus Pluto?
Divided by...
Axe equals chicken Pluto.
Equals leg.
Equals...
Equals dog?
The science ain't adding up, guys.
This ain't adding up.
Alright, we go this way.
What does this give me?
Does it give me another film?
What do the numbers mean, Doki?
What do they mean?
Be nice, another film.
Okay, we'll go this way, because I don't want to go in the bottom.
What do you mean?
It makes perfect sense.
Yeah, okay, but if you think think about it if you put the the bird on the oh the bird as the head and then the dog as the as the rest of the body you can get six chickens you can get six chickens instead of instead of one dog oh I woke up it was all just a dream it's the coma theory all over again
Um, by the way, Doki, have you ever watched the Twisted Metal series?
It's based off the game Twisted Metal.
I haven't watched the Twisted Metal series.
I know it's a voice by, what's his name?
What's his name?
Um, the guy who does Bojack Horseman.
Will Arnett.
I know it's, like, no, he's, like, the voice of the clown.
I've never played a Twisted Metal game before, actually.
I've been thinking of the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kel, thank you for the Super Chat.
Hi, Doki.
I'm sorry.
I lied about it being my one-sixth and two-hour birthday.
a reverse happy birthday to repent for my sins now you'll never get a happy birthday think about the crimes you committed that's right that's why you should never tell the truth what thank you super chat thank you thank you that's right that's what you get for telling the truth it should have kept lying Oh,
I have to fix the painting.
What an interesting piece.
The consequences.
Alright.
Oh, there's his leg.
I found...
Got his leg!
Fucking finally found his leg.
Jesus.
What do I do here?
Oh.
What?
Oh!
Okay, I get it.
Time to crawl back into the womb.
That's right.
What's in it?
By here, it has falling into the spirit.
Wait, can I just... Okay.
Yeah.
I can literally just walk through it.
What does this do?
Oh, it's less spooky now!
Yay!
I unspooked the ghost.
Unspokes your ghost.
Because the book is too bad, we had to make our way through before stopping them.
I bet Madame Leona can explain what's going on around here.
Okay.
Go this way.
Oh, there's Madame Leona!
It's the haunted mansion!
The chaos in my library must be stopped.
This haunting is out of control.
The ghost disturbing the bokehs has sent many of my prized books flying away.
First, you must seek out the broken souls that freed these spirits.
Prepare them, and the spirits will leave my bookcases.
Second, collect the flyaway books that are still in this room.
I sent Ghost Eden to Bog Easy to retrieve one of my books.
As suspected, he has failed me.
If I see him again, I shall make a bookmark of him.
But how do I catch a flying book?
Regardless of all that, restore my art collection.
My paintings have also fallen in a disarray.
in chaos, I understand you have much to attend to.
However, I insist that you calm the rest of spirits in the lab before I can allow you to leave.
Alright.
A little bit left.
Oh, hey.
What's this?
Oh, it was just nothing.
Where ghost...
She sure doesn't want things to be haunted.
Okay, how do I catch this ghost?
Do I just start painting it?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I just start painting it.
I was a little confused.
I was like, what will stop him?
What does this do?
The books, they've stopped.
Secret Panda concealed the scar.
Let's go fix it.
Oh, okay.
It's time.
Don't worry, I'm running.
I'm running.
I'm gonna make it.
Wee.
The spirits must really like you.
They shifted the bookies into a stair formation.
Shall we go up?
Yay!
Only one skull remains to be repaired.
You're doing very well, Mickey.
Yippee!
I'm a hero.
There's something over there, though.
I'm gonna go over there first.
Actually, let's go over there.
No running in my library.
I'm gonna run all I want.
I'm gonna run with scissors.
That's a little bit dumb.
Like, how is that going to crush me?
Oh, shit.
Get down from there!
Get down!
The power of the paint compels you!
Okay, so we gotta...
There we go.
Where the fuck do I hit that?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, what side is this supposed to be?
Okay.
One.
two wait there you go all right we restored that painting we just need to get the books oh there he is you can't tell me what to do i'm gonna run with scissors oh no okay i'm fine it is not because i ran with scissors there well aren't you helpful for a price i could help you give me And I'll round up.
You know what?
Yeah, fuck it.
I'm outsourcing.
There you go.
It was easy.
I'm an excellent flyer.
Bye.
I did it, guys.
For one that shared my love for books, return to me.
And it's yours.
I did it, guys.
I outsource.
Outsource for cheap.
Reap the profits.
Exactly.
It's not a crime.
they did it those bookcases have settled oh my god i'm like that what was that youtuber that like um oh no a door wait what's wrong with a door there's that youtuber that bust scams out like scammers where they reside thank you wait how do i get kind of fucking oh okay i was gonna say what is this door there's no holes There's this guy that,
like, that, uh, um, I don't remember, like, the, yeah, the telephone scam.
There was, uh, he uploaded a recent video where he, like, was dressed as Darth Vader, um, because there was a scam where it's just a bunch of people, um, what was it, outsourcing tow truck companies.
And, like, all the, like, all the, the call center people were from, like, uh, was it Philippines?
was Philippines and Nigeria and one more country I forgot which one and then they were apparently making like two dollars an hour while like uh while the uh wait oh my gosh let me get past this this time a lot of company itself were making like 40k 40k K per day.
Or not even 4K.
I think it was 100 K per day or some shit.
It's crazy.
Alright.
And the employees were making like $2 an hour.
That's just...
No, that's not Disney.
And they were like outsourcing...
They were like outsourcing tow trucks.
That's crazy.
When I was, like, reading about that scab, it was fucking crazy.
Can I just encase him in the bookshelf?
And we got this guy.
And him.
Oh, wait, there's the hatchet.
There's the murder weapon.
Let's go.
We got you now.
We have the murder weapon, Leona.
That's right.
That's remained unsolved for ages.
We should take it back to Horace.
He'll know more about it.
That's right, Leona.
Your days are numbered!
I got the murder weapon!
It was such an interesting video.
Like, they basically, they, they, like, they just pay Google to be on top of the Google search.
Like, not, was it Google?
What is it?
They pay, like, someone to, like, so they could be, like, on top of the Google searches.
So when you search up for, like, you know, you know, when your car breaks down, you search for, like, tow truck services.
So they pay, like, they pay to have their their website they have like multiple websites set up in different part in different states where uh they the first results would be like their company and they set up like multiple companies multiple like pages and stuff many thanks fellas i promise to return the favor somewhere down the line and then so that you call them first and then they'll just out and then they'll like charge double the price of like other to like the actual tow truck companies i promise to favor somewhere down the line for now to stay out of leona's sight she doesn't care much for me see you soon yeah that's crazy i wonder how do you do that so i can be like how do i pay google searches so when you type dtuber i'll be the number one answer it's so interesting though
I wonder how you do that.
How do you become, like, number one result?
And, wait, that's big brain, damn.
Make myself a sponsored link.
Yeah, I caught all of my flyaway books.
Thank you.
Here, have the silver pin for your troubles.
Catch the flying books.
Yeah, I did it.
Yeah, restored my art collection.
Thank you.
Please accept this pin.
One awarded, only to those with true appreciation of fine art.
Okay.
Yeah, I played my...
Called my restless bookcases.
I did it.
I did everything you won, Leona.
Now, let me in.
Here's what...
What the fuck?
Here, this is...
Like, where did he come from?
He just...
Drop down from the fucking sky.
I have to get through that slumber.
After kind deeds, I cannot allow this evil to befall you.
I'll channel the mystic energies and use them to dispel that disgusting creature.
Melt him away in a way he will stay.
Wait, that's not good, though!
No!
Leona!
Stop!
No!
Wait!
They're good riddance.
Oh my god.
Did I do a bad thing?
Helping her?
Oh, that...
Oh, no.
Wait, she killed him.
Wait.
Was that supposed to happen?
I...
I don't know.
I don't know if he was supposed to kill me.
I don't know That seems That's not my fault right It's not my fault I can't be I can't be implicit to this crime She killed him Not me She killed him Not me I'm killed by a associate I wasn't looking I turned away What happened?
Did I actually up okay guys i need to know did i fuck up there when she killed him did i did i actually fuck up i was just i looked away i can't it's not the bystander effect i didn't even i don't even know what happened honestly i don't know okay it's okay i can pay google to erase my crime i'm pretty sure you did it best okay okay it might be intention It might be intense.
I might be fine.
I didn't I didn't kill him.
She did Oh, hey, there's a dancing skeleton spooky scary skeleton Come on send shivers down my spine
Oh my god, look at them.
They're all partying Look at them go Or maybe restart from the beginning just to be safe.
Yay, more Mickey.
Wait, that's the ending already.
Must be like other stuff down here, right?
Ow.
Okay, these spiders don't hurt though, so it's fine.
Okay, nice.
Ow.
I'm just trying to find any more films.
Okay, I knew it.
I knew there was another film.
them down here.
And then we'll just go this way.
Look at all these spooky, scary spiders.
Alright, we can go now.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm still missing so many body parts of Donald, but I swear to God, I haven't found any.
I only found like one.
Oh, there's the scary, the the scary organ.
A pipe organ is malfunctioned.
I fix him, but steam power is not my specialty.
Shall we help him?
We have to climb those pipes anyway.
How do we help?
How do we help a piano?
Top won't be easy if he's agitated.
Be careful.
Striking a sour water note with this fella could be your swan song.
How do I help him?
How do I help something that's evil?
That's mad.
Be a little grumpy right now.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta use...
Okay, we have zero anvils.
How the...
That's not good.
There has to be an anvil hidden somewhere.
How do I get anvils then?
Is there anvil here?
Anvil!
Anvil, don't go!
Where are my fucking anvils?
Assist.
Will you help me?
Sure.
Am I...
I think that's a good thing?
Am I doing a good thing?
Am I doing...
What do you mean?
Oh, no.
Take this.
pin and farewell oh i did it that's all he needed i played a tune we can head on up now yeah i played a pipe organ okay i think i did a good thing i can't tell i can never tell if i'm doing a good thing
okay I don't have an anvil
how the fuck do I get anvils I don't know right from wrong oh my god
I mean the music sounded pretty evil but maybe it's just you know maybe that's just his taste you know maybe he's not naive It's just, he just likes to, just likes a little bit of evil in his music.
That doesn't necessarily mean it's a bad thing.
Some people just have different taste in music.
Mickey is a very ambiguous character, morally ambiguous character.
Oh wait, there you go.
Maybe if I kill him.
Okay, there you go.
He'll give me, he'll give me an anvil.
Maybe he has anvils.
Strip the robot!
Get dressed so I can strip you.
Do you have anvil?
Okay, yes, he does.
Alright, we got anvil, guys.
We need to find another spot.
Oh, there's his arm.
Damn, dokey.
We got his arm.
Got your arm.
There's another spot right here.
Oh, nice.
We needed that.
We needed to get him.
Thinking it's true that what everyone says.
Well, everyone except Oswald, anyway.
What's the matter?
Oh my god, now we got Anvil sketches.
Okay.
Okay, now we get Anvil sketches.
Alright.
It's like down here.
I don't actually know what these Anvil does.
So...
So let's see.
Alright.
Possessed tables.
Why?
Why are my tables possessed?
I don't understand.
What's...
What's the point?
Why are my tables possessed?
I don't...
What...
What's the point?
Oh, it's...
Why are they flying?
Please explain why I have possessed tables.
Up we go.
Meant to get you to the second section before the...
Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
Did I do an evil thing by playing the music?
Did I...
Oh.
Wait.
No.
Surely not.
Right?
No.
Wait.
With that, you have my gratitude.
I may be small, but...
Or small, I'll strike a blow against the mad doctor.
free wait do we i want him to punch the doctor
is that bad beating up a nerd is that
the organ didn't mean evil right i don't know do i pay him to salios salios bump bump See, but yes, it's bad.
But, like, I'm not the one beating him.
I don't know.
Do I give him $100?
I...
Okay.
Here, here's $100.
Here you go.
I don't think it's a bad thing to let him...
Maybe it's not that bad.
bad.
Guys, maybe it's not that bad.
Celius.
Oh no.
I don't know.
He wanted to play the piano, so I play the piano.
How was I supposed to know?
I don't know if it's good or not.
This is morally ambiguous.
It's so morally ambiguous, I don't know!
Stellius, Stellius, God, those Stellius...
Okay.
I mean, it stopped playing evil music!
So it can't be that bad!
The music, evil music stopped!
The more unpingity the beating up...
He's a bad nerd!
he's not good nerd he's a very bad man like it's not like okay like some of these choices some of these choices are easier like do you want to give a veteran PTSD or not and then we get this it's stopping the evil is like playing an evil song on the evil organ to stop the evil music good or bad like how how do what I know how I play the evil music but he stopped playing more evil music I is beating up is beating up a doctor who may or may not be like mentally ill but is doing a lot of evil things bad or good.
Like how am I supposed to know it's morally ambiguous yes I'm beating him up yes he may or may not be crazy slash mentally ill but he did a lot of bad things so like is it bad or good?
I don't know.
He doesn't have mad in his name Like, I don't know This won't hold up in court That's actually a fair point Ready to go to the lonesome manner And follow your heart
Alright Alright Alright Ooh, there's like squishy sounds I mean, it doesn't, it's not great.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
My favorite philosopher, Epic Mickey.
Wait, is this like, I knew it.
I knew that was a hidden exit.
Look at them.
They're all dancing for me.
It's hitting a mentally ill insane man in the face of me.
Morally correct.
Am I supposed to...
Okay, it's this way.
No!
Wait, will they respawn?
Ow.
That's...
Oh, yeah, it respawns.
Okay, that's good.
Ow!
Grandma!
That's not cool, Grandma.
Okay, scary.
Yeah, I made it.
I just barely made it.
Okay, there better be a goddamn film right over here.
Alright, let's see if I'll make this jump.
Wait, what was the point?
Oh my god, there was no point.
There was actual no point.
It was not worth it.
For the adventure, dokey.
Wait.
It's for it.
Where's your sense of adventure?
Is he doing there?
Anything back here?
Oh my god.
For the love of the game.
Okay.
Yes.
Yeah, they give us a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, it's my unbirthday.
Can I get a happy unbirthday?
Of course.
Now crawl back.
It's fine.
I don't need that film.
Ha!
You're persistent, but there's no way you'll make it through this attic.
TV.
Step.
What the fuck?
Through the attic.
He'll be able to create an endless supply.
You can't get to the mad doctor.
if we could use the tracks to our advantage like i promise i'm here to return the favor for finding and releasing me i'm afraid of madame leona but i think the mad the mad doctor is a let my trusty ranch dismantle one of those irritating beetleworks generators for you okay okay so if i don't jam the machines um Everything will be okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right.
It's no match for us.
Stop calling me, Doc.
I'll find a way to stop you, Mickey.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The stream will be shown in an ethics philosophy, physiology class about overthinking simple moral questions.
Two more BetoWorks generators left.
promise.
Gremlin's stuff this will now deliver.
Watch as reduce this Bidowork's generator to a useless hulk.
Is this a good thing or a bad thing?
Okay, I got rid of him.
Alright, he's down.
Mickey can't be stopped when he's on a road.
It's a mad dog your Bidowork's army, you wretched Gremlin.
Get it, right?
just one more generator okay it's just one more to go surely if it's okay everything will be okay i just need to figure out how if i don't kill any of them it should be fine okay i have to fix this okay how do i fix it
attracts and then it'll be fine if i don't kill maybe if i don't kill the robots
right if i don't kill the robots then i'm not doing a bad thing
question mark it's not bad if i i i i don't kill Kill him?
Okay, things will be okay.
We gotta restore the tracks.
Somehow.
Oh, wait, there's his torso.
Wait, I found his torso.
Don't worry, Donald.
I got your ass.
Got your ass.
Nice.
Got it.
Is that everything?
And try...
Okay.
If I...
Wait, no, I did.
I smooth things over.
Okay, okay, the red...
The other part might be with Donald.
What the fuck?
Give it...
Give back Donald's ass!
Dorky, it's not your...
That's not yours, Dorky.
You know that.
I own Donald Duck, I'm Mickey Mouse.
Okay.
Oh, that's fucked up, bro.
Oh, the TV.
I have a TV.
What did I do?
Wait, but what did I do?
I don't fucking know what I did.
What the fuck did I do with the TV?
Did I do anything?
I can't tell.
what the machine do what is it powering up
is he just watching my TV oh I had to stand on it there you go okay
what is this did I break it oh no okay how do I get this up though I have to get this one up
and if you're How to lower this one?
How the fuck?
How the fuck do I lower this?
Alright.
We go this way.
Oh, it's over here.
I just need to step on it.
What did I do?
What the fuck?
I don't know.
I'll never know what I do.
That's the thing.
I just...
I don't know.
Oh my god, there's the evil queen.
Okay.
I need to make sure I don't kill any of them.
Ow.
It's okay, I can dodge it.
I'm gaming.
I just press buttons.
That's all I do.
I'm like trying to figure out how to like make sure...
I have to lower this track, but like how do I...
Oh, no.
Where is this track connected to?
I never know.
That's my little secret.
Like, how do I...
Unattach this?
I can't unpaint it.
Here?
I can unpaint this, right?
No?
How do I unpaint you?
What the fuck?
How the fuck do I unpaint you?
Like, it's just there.
Oh, is that a button?
No, that's not a button.
Unpaints your thing.
Yeah, it's just there.
It won't let me unpaint it.
I just need to lower this, but I don't know where that is connected to.
It's just one thing.
It's literally this one thing.
Was there a wheel?
I don't see no wheel.
That's where I found Donald's ass right there.
I'm so lost.
I'm trying to figure this out, guys.
I pressed all the buttons.
What more is there?
What more do I have to press?
I pressed them on.
It's all powered up.
Probably a switch on the wall.
Okay, maybe.
me.
It's literally this.
This is literally the one thing.
I'd be like, is there anything here?
No.
Yeah, there's nothing here.
Like, I need this to jump up there.
Oh my god, I'm so confused.
What could it be?
I did.
This was a TV.
I used a TV for this.
I powered it up.
And then I pressed this button.
is there anything here is it evil if it falls down you saw what happened he fell you all saw what happened and he fell
i didn't know anything he tripped guys he tripped it's not my fault
can't reveal okay let me
But I pressed this button, too.
It's literally this platform!
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is up?
How do I deal with this platform?
Maybe it's somewhere here.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm missing something here.
Okay, but I want the money too I
want this
okay no definitely yeah maybe is there anything here okay I didn't kill all of them because I didn't kill all of them it should still be like I should still be okay
Nothing here.
Oh my god.
How do I lower the last box?
How do I lower you?
It's just you!
Please get down!
I don't understand.
I need both buttons?
Which one?
This one?
I swear to God, if that's not true, I swear to God.
Okay, there's one.
And then there's the other one.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, that's all I needed.
I, oh my God.
That's all I needed.
this
game was made for children
impossible those machines are indestructible and by the way it's mad doctor oh you'll pay for this micky mouse i did it i fixed the tracks you've lost doc now where's your peel works army i haven't lost even now i got you'll see meet again as a conqueror you're an animatronic at least you understand when the bolt absorbs all the pain in wasteland only we animatronics will survive and when the last time my instrument no but is he dead gee do you think he needed this let's go back to the civilization your plan painter theater can change based on how you do important characters and ways that yeah i got the pain looks like that's the way out i'll back to the main street that wasn't evil right he was a mean robot i got all the robot parts wait did i got all the robot parts did i get i'm missing like his torso okay that should be fine that's not an evil thing i did Can we go back now?
Return to Bog Easy?
Yeah, I got blue, so it's okay.
I didn't want to risk it.
I didn't want to risk killing the robots.
Because, like, they were...
It was not their fault that they're evil.
You know?
They were made that way.
Maybe leaving, but you earned this because of what you did for Madam Leona.
Yay!
I got books!
the ghost returned to the millionaire as soon as you fix the organ I can't say we'll miss this place you aren't y'all weren't that much fun anyway yes eyes I hear something big is happening our Mickey junk mountain the more distance I put myself between them and that place the better before I forgot I want you to have this piece of Donald oh it was you you what were you doing with his fucking why are these random people doing with the body parts what are you doing we got bored of oh kicking her around okay when you hurry back to Mean Street.
Oz will be waiting for us there.
Okay, they were kicking around.
Poor Donald.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, I got his body parts.
I have the murder weapon.
Alright, everything is looking good.
Don't worry, Donald.
Oh boy, oh boy.
You have all my parts!
That's well!
I don't know how people do the fucking Donald voice.
I don't know what the fuck they do with their throat.
Aw, get some things never change.
Uh-huh.
Yay!
Right before I left Aashtown, my tugboat sank in the lake!
I mean, you should be able to get the thinner pumped up, but he'll need this gear.
Take the gear to Moody.
He knows what to do.
Who the fuck is Moody?
Okay, it must be like...
one of the gremlins.
Because I'm like, who the fuck is that guy?
Okay.
Okay, I gotta go back to the other place.
Okay, no, that's the veteran.
Oh, I'll go back.
Oh, hey, there's my... There's a painting over there.
Wait, I never grabbed the painting when I stole her face?
Alright.
Nice.
Look at that.
See, look at all the good stuff I've done.
I've matched up I'm not good.
Wait, where's the...
Where the fuck is the projector?
Oh, it's over there.
I was like, where is the projector?
Is this one?
God, it's so far.
Why isn't there, like, a projector in the town?
Like, that's much more convenient.
Why do I have to travel all the way here?
Wait, what's she doing here?
Hey, what are you doing next to the boat?
Hello?
Ma'am?
What are you doing here?
Has before... Oh my god, it's the fucking race woman.
God, get help.
Please get out.
Yes, I like to skip these.
Not everything is about racing, guys.
If I talk to Oswald, it progresses, so... Oh, fuck.
force to talk to him.
There you are.
The Shadow Bolt has marshaled all the botlings they could summon.
They're climbing up Mickey Junk Mountain to attack my fortress.
They're trying to...
Well, never mind what they're trying to do.
I need your help.
They gotta be repelled before I can help you launch the rocket.
Take all you can carry.
If those guys loyal to the Bolter up there, it's gonna be tough even for someone as great as you.
Alright.
I gotta...
Oswald needs help.
Okay, where am I?
Quest?
Uh...
Give the murder weapon.
Wait, actually.
Let's give him the films first.
Yay!
Oh, I got a new costume!
I'm a construction worker!
Wait.
Look at me go.
I have a hat.
That's when you know I'm certified.
Okay.
I got an extra TV sketch.
How many fucking achievements do I have?
Oh my god.
It's not paying attention.
Oh, God!
I'm a firefighter.
I'm certified.
That's all you need.
You just need a hat.
I didn't realize I could have got a...
I'm at the last level, and now I have...
Oh, my God.
Now I got all the rewards.
There we go.
That's all you need.
You just need a hat.
And then you're certified.
That's what Team Fortress 2 taught me.
Ooh, it's sealed.
Tiki Mask and why?
Candle and Bog, it walked away from Louie's shack out in the swamp.
I knew you could find it.
I do it, but I hear their ghost stare.
Poke around and see if you could find some clues.
Are you serious?
I just came from Bog.
I'm going to prove I'll shout it out that Constance, this will be a relief to not just Moody, but everyone in the park.
It's all thanks to you.
My business is start booming any day now, and maybe Pete will...
Oh, your business.
Yes, you totally did all the hard work, Horace.
Everything?
Okay.
Uh, fine, I'm missing Canada.
Wait, what were the failed quest?
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
We don't need...
He doesn't need a read.
That's fine.
He didn't need a read anyway.
Okay, let's give the film to Pete real quick.
Big bad Pete.
Okay, we're not gonna send the children to jail.
I'll be an even better leader after I watch this.
This is priceless.
Good thing for me, didn't recognize the true value of these cartoons.
I'll give you these e-tickets and a Pirate Spark, but I got the best end of this deal.
Is that everything?
Um...
I'll fix Donna's boat and then we'll call it here.
We'll not call it.
We'll go to Mickey Junk Mountain.
All right.
We can't arrest children, Pete.
There's a reason why they go to Juvee instead of jail for murder.
This way.
Let's fix his boat.
All right.
Wait for them to turn 18.
Then you can arrest the children.
Because they won't be children no more.
It's a long waiting game.
Alright.
This has to be Moody, right?
Who the fuck is Moody?
Oh, is it him?
Oh!
Okay, yeah, there we go.
I'm sorry, I assumed the fucking guy that was gonna fix it was the Gremlin and not the pirate.
I'll try to spy with Captain Hook while it's confined.
I did it.
I fixed the boat.
it should...
I mean, like, obviously when you're saying, like, someone's gonna fix the boat, you assume it's the Gremlins, because that's all they were doing.
They were the fixers.
He's a pirate.
A pirate doesn't fix.
A pirate seals.
No.
Get me out.
Did I not give him $10?
Get me out of here.
Okay.
Please.
I'll give you $10.
Okay, there you go.
Yes.
Here's $10.
Alright.
Where's Mickey Junk Mountain?
Wait, this is Mickey Junk Mountain.
Oh my god.
I...
I was going there.
Okay, I'm gonna pee.
That was Mickey.
junk mountain okay i'll be right back
i am back it's time to go to mickey junk mountain and climb mickey junk all right let's go time to climb all right and then we gotta go up climbing mickey's junk you ready to climb my junk guys
the humor of a 13-year-old boy.
Do we need to stop?
Come on, fellas!
Huh?
Alright.
Off we go.
Wait, is there...
What I have to do?
Okay, fire...
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I think I was supposed to talk to Oswald, right?
No, Oswald would meet me there.
It's not going to climb itself, boys.
Someone's going to do it.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Oh, shit.
Can that thing run me over?
Let's try.
I'm asking the real questions here.
Your battle will be legendary.
Wee.
Oh my god.
Oh my.
This has to be the fucking slowest train.
Oh my god.
No, my $20.
Wait, am I dead?
Oh, I got squashed.
Jesus.
This race is so slow.
Fucking finally.
I swear to God, Oswald better be here.
I swear to God.
Okay, he is.
Thank God.
Oswald?
Where's Oswald?
Oswald!
Hello?
Where is he?
glad to see you haven't shaken out yet come on guys let's get up to the mountain together you and your new best friend can't travel the way i do i'm going straight to the jug but i'm afraid you fellas will have to climb and it's gonna be tough enter the projector stream i'll be right behind you all right where is it is right here i'm ready to head to the summit let's go let's go Oh,
Mickey Mouse.
Oh, this is new.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'm a firefighter.
I'm here to save the world.
Don't worry, everyone.
I don't think I need to get any reels anymore, I feel that.
But we gotta grab this, though.
Noik, my painting.
I don't think we have enough to, like, unlock any more special stuff so so you can just skip everything here
oh shit wait who's here oh it's the king wait I recognize this short I recognize the character what did I open open so many things yeah I got all the cosmetics but what does I do?
Oh, here.
Oh, it's just fast travel.
Yay!
It's a shortcut!
Yippee!
Wait, where does this go?
Hello?
Flying up.
Oh, never mind.
I got one real.
I just did it for this.
Oh, shit.
Almost fell off.
I just did it because I can.
Oh my god.
Did he draw himself as the king?
Egotistical much?
I say as Mickey has a fucking has fucking statues of him everywhere Hello, I'm here to climb Mickey's junk Looks like he needs our help we can't let Wait, what's going on?
What is he doing?
It's a shadow bolt Look at the size of him Okay, can I just paint him?
Can he be friendly?
Friend?
Am I...
Am I doing it?
Is he turning friendly?
Are you...
Friendly?
Yeah!
Do you think he likes it?
Surely you turning bluer?
I can't tell.
Friend?
Is this friend color?
Look at him!
He's turning bluer!
He is!
Look at him!
That's right!
I'll force you to...
I'll love bomb you!
That's right!
Love bomb!
Oh my god.
Ow, that hurts.
That's not what you do for your friends.
Friend!
He's turning blue, it's working!
Oh shit.
No mercy.
Force friendship is the best type of friendship!
Oh my god, okay, we gotta turn these guys into friends first too.
Don't worry, they don't know, they don't know what they're missing out.
Guys.
it's okay because they don't know what they're missing out goodness
it's okay i just keep oh shit he's choking on it yes
he's choking on the friend juice let's go
joke on my friendship probably don't worry I'm fine see praise okay I need more friendship juice I gotta remember to hydrate okay Remember the higher trait so you can produce more friendship juice?
I'm sorry.
I'm so childish.
Toki, you are not sorry.
Guys, I'm sorry.
Oh, shit, my heart.
Ow.
Oh, shit.
That's not good.
No!
No, I wasn't picked!
Okay, that's deserved.
That's deserved.
That's honestly, I deserve it.
I deserve it.
I do.
I can't believe I did do it from the start.
Are you serious?
Bro.
It was my bad.
I actually threw...
I'm pretty sure I was like one hit too.
I literally was walking into all of them.
I deserve it.
God.
That's being too... That's being too childish.
I'm sorry.
They know I've sinned.
I wonder, like, if this affects it.
Or do I just dodge it until he...
Until he wants to, like, you know...
Until he wants to, like, fly.
I can't tell.
Okay.
I gotta...
Get that guy out of the way.
way.
Ow!
How did that hurt me?
Oh.
That's five.
You'll land soon.
You'll have to land soon, guys.
There you go.
And then I...
Come on.
Suck it.
That's right.
Into the mouth it goes.
My friendship.
Okay, I'll stop.
I'll stop.
That's when you know he and I We're best friends
She won't stop She lies Toki, you said you'd stop Okay, okay, now I stop They make it so easy.
Like, look at this.
It's not my fault.
They're like walking into it.
They set it up for me.
How is this my fault?
It's perfectly set up.
I put set up.
Oh my god, they're all dead.
All my friends are dead.
You need help, don't you?
Star, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Now they're best friends.
That's right.
I'm a fireman.
I'm just using my hose, guys.
I'm just doing my job, guys.
I'm just doing my job.
And I'm spraying my hose into his mouth.
Look, he's choking.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And a job well done.
We can be good friends, sir.
Yes!
He enjoyed it.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
Now we're together.
Feet down.
We're freaky now.
See, I told you!
He liked it.
And that's how you become friends.
Yeah, cuddling.
Remember to cuddle after.
Look at that.
And a boo.
Help.
See, now we're best friends.
Thanks, that was a close one.
No one else has made it.
What's in it?
The bolt.
What?
But I've been fighting the bolt.
You haven't seen the real bolt.
A long time back.
You saved Waste and I lost Ortenzia.
I stay here on the mountain to guard the jug.
The guys you fought are just trippings.
Oh, I didn't mention that before.
important to mention.
Mickey Mouse!
We want me to start over and shake on proof!
He just murdered it!
A while ago, I found this workshop.
A pair of paint and thinner.
Things got out of control.
I spilled the jug onto the gateway to this place.
I caused the thinner disaster.
You!
I'm really sorry.
Uh-huh.
I should have known you stole my life and ruined my home?
That's it.
You and me, Mouse.
Right now, point him up.
I've been waiting this for years.
This is finally gonna be my moment.
Wait.
Did I get the bad ending?
Oswald No
No I did so much No Wait no this is not over right No
It might not be over It's not over It's not over guys I still have time I still have time I still have time to use my friendship beam one last time.
Wait, what?
Oh, oh, it's because I'm like his dad.
Oh, my God.
They choked him to death.
He's like, dad, dad.
My heart.
Oh.
Where's Oswald?
Oswald?
I bet you're sorry you had to save me.
That's why they call me the Lucky Rabbit.
It's even bigger than I remember.
Oh no.
What are those?
Those bloodicles will absorb all the pain in the wasteland.
Looks like it's up to us, Gus.
Let's get to Haustown.
Oh my god, it's not over yet.
There's still hope, guys.
It's endgame time.
Oh no!
Everything is gone!
Haustown is overrun by bloodicles.
They're everywhere.
It's okay.
I have my heart.
and then we get this out one out of four with the power of friendship and the keyblade i will have my heart back it's okay my long hose will save the world i'm a firefighter guys pass the test jokey i don't think you're licensed to be a the more you talk the more More I feel like you're not licensed to be a firefighter.
Of course I am.
Don't you see my hat?
Guys, look, I have a hat.
Oh my god, he beat him up.
Okay, nice.
What is he just doing?
Oh my god, people are like fucking dying and he's just...
Let's get rid of the tentacles, though.
Let's pop the tentacle pimples.
And that is last tentacle right here.
I'm a certified firefighter.
I'm, like, worried to use, like, the green stuff because it's a...
It's the bad.
It's the bad paint.
It looks like we cleared out the bloodicles from Maw's town.
Yay!
Okay, I did.
Oh my god.
They came back.
It's a miracle.
Okay, we gotta go back to the town now.
I want to get rid of the green attack, but I can't.
I did it!
I got more HP!
Nice!
Okay.
Let's go back to Mean Street.
Oh, I still have to- I'm here to save the world and you're still gonna make me pay ten dollars they're like you want to save the you want to save my world ten dollars please i'm literally doing this for free like i'm this is literally charity work for me i still have to pay that man i'm starting to see why he liked you more focus deadly peril remember he has daddy issues us will definitely has daddy issues you know folks here would die for a heart and you gave up Remling just meant?
You'd have done the same.
Huh?
Maybe for my whole new bunch, Oh, Tensia.
But you?
Now you're stuck here like me.
Now Donald Duck can finally be the main character.
The rocket is useless.
No one can get out of here without the heart.
No one?
Well, it's not important now.
We've lost.
That's over.
God will destroy everything.
We're just giving up.
We've had a fight.
Uh-huh.
Fight what?
That storm?
We can't even reach it.
The true ending, Donald Duck, finally gets to be the main character.
Bring the fight to the blood.
That won't defeat the blood.
It can't regain its strength.
These bloodicles feed it all.
The penguin means.
I'll take care of the bloodicles.
You fix the rocket.
Uh-huh.
But could we really...
Sure, give me the parts.
Then meet me in the rocket in Tomorrow City.
Now I really do see why.
Oh, wait.
Okay, I have to take...
I have to help them.
Don't worry, guys!
Pop pop!
Click pop pop!
Okay, we gotta turn him into Algoor.
Turn him into Algoor, too.
Okay.
I want to use the bad move right now.
So, oh, I can't go.
I can't use it.
Okay, but what?
What?
It's one move.
One, one time.
It's one time.
It's just one guy.
It's just really that bad.
It's the Stokey of the Earth.
It's one guy.
Is it really that bad?
It died.
Toki, it died.
What do you mean is it really that bad?
He's dead.
That's how it starts.
Then you want to keep doing it.
Don't worry.
No, no, no.
I resisted.
It's just one time.
Oh my god, he's a big boy!
Look at him go!
It's fine.
It might...
Okay, yeah, he's slowly turning blue.
He's slowly turning blue, it's working.
I just gotta feed him.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Let him keep sucking.
Give him the friendship juice.
See, look, he's slowly blue!
Okay, nice.
Yay!
We're all friends now.
Look at him!
He's so happy!
Okay, we gotta get this.
Wait, is he not friend?
No, he is.
He was just collateral damage.
Yay!
Okay, I need to have HP, though.
Should be...
Oh, one more pimple.
for.
Pocked it!
This is all your fault, Doki.
That's it.
You're out of the Mickey Mouse Club.
Same.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The lot sold, Doki's heart before I could.
Oh, man.
Oh, okay.
We have to make sure everybody is okay.
Alright, I helped Mean Street.
Did I finish all the...
Okay, yeah.
Wait, how many...
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
now we gotta do we did oh boogie boogie island okay oh the tiki room in the tiki tiki tiki tiki room okay yes let me skip we gotta save the tiki room this should help me those splatters already there let's get going save venture land don't worry i got this
Okay, one, two, three, we're doing it.
Oh, wait, four.
That should be everything, right?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
How many?
Oh, my.
It's all the way up this time.
I have to do parkour for this.
That's fucked up.
All right, I have to do parkour to pop these.
okay and then then there's one over here oh my god how much how many okay one hour that wasn't one I that was only one wait there's one that's threatening tiki sab oh shit I forgot about you sorry tiki sab tiki sab Tiki, Tiki, it all.
Okay.
Oh, you poor thing.
You have to parkour.
So sad.
Alright.
We did it.
We saved him.
We saved Sam.
Wait, is he good or bad?
Yeah, he's good.
You can't tell him if they're good or bad.
Because they're just the same.
They're still purple.
Oh my god.
They're all like...
They're all ganged up on this poor man.
Okay, one.
Wait, are they fighting someone?
No, they're not.
What the fuck is that sound?
There's something, like, behind this tentacle.
Alright.
There we go.
Almost done.
But the last...
Oh my god, it's not almost done.
I forgot the parkour section.
There's more.
We have to go higher.
I'll go as high as we've never gotten before.
Alright, there we go.
Great job, Mickey.
But there are more Flotacos to fight.
Let's head to Bog Easy.
Okay, Bog Easy and then the Spacetown.
And then we should be good.
Alright, time to pay my taxes.
To save your fucking world.
No, I don't need to repaint everything.
people can do it themselves i did my bare minimum
i did the minimum that i needed to do
okay my 10 ticket tax
yippee the bare minimum i sure do like doing the bare minimum all right don't worry we're here to save the veteran Okay.
Wait, I never seen these guys before.
They were little silly hats.
Look at them and their little silly hats.
Oh my god.
They're new.
Alright.
Just gotta paint this guy.
Wait, I thought we're friends!
What the fuck?
Oh, now we're...
Okay, I didn't realize.
Okay, now we're friends.
Alright, there we go.
Is it all painted?
Oh.
Oh, it's all the way over there.
Oh my god.
How far do these tentacles go?
Okay, and then paint this guy.
Holy shit.
How far does this tentacle go?
It's everywhere.
Freaking little maze I'm doing.
Okay.
It's gonna do a thank god.
Thank god my brush goes really far Why can't they help me?
Like their whole thing is that they paint and they don't even help me paint That's fucked up.
What's the point of being your friend if you don't help me out buddy?
Be blue.
All right They're also doing the bare minimum
You're just doing what you're doing, Doki.
They learn from the best.
Oh, shit.
You're evil.
You're all evil.
I didn't realize you're all evil.
You all look blue.
I didn't know they're evil.
They already looked.
I-what?
That's fine.
It's okay.
I didn't do it.
I didn't cause his death.
He did it himself.
I didn't do it.
That's fine.
He caused his own death, guys.
It wasn't my fault.
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
They did it to themselves.
Yeah, I need to grab health, though.
Yeah, I knew that was health.
Okay.
Nice.
look look he he did it he did it i i get okay i would admit it would be assisted manslaughter but like but like i didn't do it though i might have assisted but like it's not my fault he was in the way there's the last green that's like that's like only like what five years
Toki, stop a minute.
Please talk to your lawyer.
Yay!
Okay, we did it.
We gotta go back to Mean Street.
Alright.
Yeah, I assisted and he didn't die.
That's less of a hard...
That's like a lesser sense.
sentence if he lives.
You know why he's angry at this time?
Huh?
That's the voodoo doll?
That's the mystery who made it.
Someone sold a doll before I could break the curse.
They must be using it to annoy Donald.
Why would anybody make a voodoo doll?
Donald?
Oh, never mind.
Why the fuck?
I got broken all the pieces and then those lousy ghosts show up here?
What's the big idea?
After you That, you go running away, not precious to show up.
Then right after that, I got back to get it.
What happens that splatter?
Ever since that stupid looking getting got here, I'm a serious pain.
I'm not kidding, Mickey.
You'll find out why that splatter is here, Mickey.
I owe you one.
What?
Bro, I need to save the world, Donald.
Why?
I restore them for me.
Just come back when they're all...
Bro, I need to save the world!
I did?
Oh, I did it!
I want to have this power spark and pin as a...
Like, I don't fucking know.
I don't...
What?
How the fuck do I save you?
Lies in the swamp.
Back there?
You have to go to...
A veteran?
What did that veteran do?
Look, the dog!
Oh, shit!
Oh, that's fucked up.
Oh, my god.
Hey.
Head.
Oh, shit!
Boar?
Was that just...
Did he just got bored?
I wonder who we should return.
turn it to.
I guess to Donald.
Wait, how did he...
Did he poop that out?
Tookie, please.
Alright.
Hello, Donald.
It doesn't even look like me.
I hope you gave that spatter what it had coming.
When is something even worse, gets it.
I know.
Can you find somebody who likes me to keep it safe?
Don't say it.
Lots of folks like me.
I probably shouldn't keep it myself.
Oh, okay.
I'll just give it to Daisy.
Daisy likes you.
Alright.
I'll find Daisy.
Okay, it's this way.
Okay, like, he literally ate the duck.
Like...
It was right there.
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta give this to Daisy.
I'm pretty sure Daisy likes him.
Right?
Yeah, it has to be.
That's his girlfriend.
Surely, okay, I don't know.
Maybe it's a bad idea to give, like, a dog that...
Actually, no.
That's actually a really bad idea.
You do not want to give a voodoo dog to your significant other.
Because, like, you know, what if you piss them off?
That's too much power.
Now that I think about it.
That may or may not be too much at power.
Let's give...
That seems an incredibly...
That seems like it'll lead to an incredibly toxic relationship.
Anyway, let's give the doll to Daisy.
Wait, no, Daisy doesn't live here.
Daisy lives in...
Uh...
Daisy lives in the Tikiuro.
This is where...
Wait, goofy!
Goofy!
can take care of the dog.
He's too ignorant to do anything bad with it.
Oh, he doesn't care.
He's... Never mind.
He's...
He's too ignorant.
He's so ignorant that he doesn't care.
Yeah, he's responsible.
He has a teenage son.
That's crazy.
Pete and...
Pete and Goofy are the only two characters.
That...
That bangs.
You think about it.
Alright.
Yeah, Pete and Goofy both have sons.
He yucks, guys.
They both yucks.
Okay, but Pete's wife is kind of a patty.
I don't know what...
I don't even know what Pete's wife looks like.
I don't even remember what Pete's wife looks like.
Is this a doll?
How cute.
It looks just like Donald.
May I keep it, please?
I promise to take very good care of it.
Wait.
Is it a good ending if I give it to Daisy?
Will she actually take really good care of it?
Guys, is this a bad or also what the fuck is going on with the cow slam dunking into that thing?
Yes.
I mean, like, who else do I give it to?
Why is this a yes or no question?
Was there someone else I could have given it to?
Who else would have taken the fucking voodoo dog?
Why is it a yes or no?
Um, I trust my heart.
happen to it okay surely surely this was a good thing i did right did
i do okay no more guys night free donald did i did i do the right thing
Oh no Yeah, I give it to her Why Pete?
Why is Pete in this equation?
Yeah Like who the fuck thinks like I'm gonna give it to Pete When you get the doll?
Like why is he even in the equation?
Yeah, right?
Pete?
Like where did he come from?
first just to be mean because he is a bad option yeah bad guy Pete he love you Pete will treat him right guys I just want to make sure that I don't have to talk to him or anything I was gonna see if I have to talk to Donald I guess so that you can get the pure evil route I watched the ending of the evil route just Because,
like, I got curious.
Because, obviously, like, it's something I can't have.
And, like, evil Mickey is actually crazy.
He literally just kills everyone in this world.
Like, because you have to do a lot of evil things to act.
Like, you have to purposely do every evil thing you can to get the evil ending.
Okay.
Why are you so angry?
I saved your fucking life.
And, like, basically, he literally kills everyone.
this world and he's like he and he enjoyed it this is what you're preventing me from doing
that could have been me guys all right it's too late we're already committed to the good route it's like the genocide route in undertale but instead of But it's Disney characters.
Joki watching the evil...
Yeah, I live vicariously through other people doing evil deeds.
Okay.
Watching the evil...
Like me watching food videos on that.
Oh, shit, nice.
No more logicals.
Yeah.
I'm done here.
You want to travel?
Yes.
It's time.
Tomorrow, city time.
It's time to go to Pluto.
Oh, it's the...
It's the cat.
God above this cat.
Hello,
cat.
No.
No, this is Pluto's dream.
That's not...
It's not...
This was Pluto's stream, guys.
It's not my...
It's not Mickey's stream.
It's Pluto's stream.
Remember that.
My freaky-ass dog.
This is my dog being a freak.
Oh, shit.
Ow.
That's fine.
I just need to get to the other side.
But, um...
Make me freak the owner.
What the fuck did I do?
Mickey, the bloodicles blocking space barrage.
Entrance need to go.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
These guys don't pose any threats to me.
At best, we just get rid of...
Get rid of the blots, though.
The blots are the problem.
Nice.
Alright, where's the other one?
Where does it start?
Oh, shit!
Don't worry.
Serpentine, ow.
That's not fair.
Me touching the pin hurts me?
Alright, let's grab this.
Oh my god, it's so far.
Fuck this.
Oh my god, fuck!
Okay.
These guys are so annoying, I have to get them out.
Alright.
Pop pop!
Pop!
I think this part of the quest, this part of the level is so tedious.
Ow.
It's not cool, bro.
But that's not cool.
Bro, come on, bro.
It's not cool, buddy.
Where's the last tentacle?
Oh, it's over there.
Alright.
It's so tedious.
Because it's literally just walking around trying to find it.
And just spray the goop.
Yay!
Nice job!
Time to go!
Wait, we're here?
I assume it's over there, right?
Yeah, I feel like this part, they're definitely padding playtime for this part.
Alright, down I go.
So let me beat up the boss already.
Let me, let me add him.
Let me, let me force him to be my friend.
Yes.
Alright.
It's a boxing match, right?
Oh yeah, this is a robot boxing match.
Okay, I should be allowed to, like, fucking pay to skip for this.
Like, why are they making me do this again?
Oh my god, someone please save the monkey.
He's dead.
Oh my god, he's not even breathing.
Oh, he's not even blinking.
Oh my god, this is so fucked up.
that body anymore.
He's not even breathing anymore.
He's stopping on the dead monkey.
Alright.
It's the final countdown.
Looks like you have some bloodicles to take care of, Mickey.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
There's more bloodicles!
Oh my god.
Okay, where is...
It's okay, he can't climb stairs.
That's fucking right, I knew you can't reach me, bitch.
That's fine.
You're no threat to me.
Look at you, you're so slow.
Do I have this already?
Yeah, I do.
It's just money.
All right, Apako.
That's fine.
Nice.
Oh, two more to go!
It's over here.
It's so tedious!
Fuck this.
Alright, fight him.
Go beat him up.
Go beat him up, I don't care.
I'm doing the real job now.
As long as I'm not the one that's killing them, I should be fine.
Okay, nice.
Dave.
Is that the last one?
Oh, please tell me that's the last one.
Nice.
Alright.
One more.
Wait, good or bad?
Bad.
There you go.
Now you're good.
Someone, please, give this boticle a skincare routine.
This ain't healthy, buddy.
Oh, thank God.
It's not that bad.
Okay, that's It was just three blots.
Hello, Oswald.
All the bloticles are destroyed.
Now the rock is ready for liftoff.
Not too bad, Mickey.
I probably could have done it better.
But I was late.
Come on, let's blast off.
Up I go.
Bro, this bloticle actually has Nina's skincare routine.
That ain't healthy for the skin.
It's so moisturized.
It's too oily.
He's letting it all build up.
Did you forget to fill it up?
Oh my god.
How fucking big is this thing?
Alright, we head for the heart.
When we get close, we hit the self-destruct.
That's gonna hurt.
Just speaking personally.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is it?
What is it?
Oh, it's absorbing the pants because it's...
I feel so uncomfortable by that.
It was kind of a budget issue.
It's okay.
We're at the head.
I'm losing her.
Wait, I think we can reach.
What happened?
Can we reach it?
That was quite a crash.
You've been out for a while.
got you to the control tower when you came through.
He also said something about launching a fireworks show before he hopped off.
He's out there distracting the bloc to buy his time to get up there.
Goodness, this is where you and I first met.
Looks like Flinner has flooded the place.
Think we can drain it?
How do we drain it?
Oh, we have to fix that.
Okay.
I gotta meet Oswald in the control tower, but we gotta fix this first.
Back where it all started, guys.
Oh, that's cool.
I didn't notice that.
There's like the... Oh, okay, no, that's... That's... He's my teammate.
Okay, he freaked me out, guys.
Guys, bro, you freaked... Bro, you don't... Don't do that, bro.
That's not cool.
It's so cool, though.
Look at... There's, like, the Disney villains.
But also, that's not cool, bro.
Don't freak out.
Don't... Don't just... Yeah, just do that to another bro, man.
there okay yeah i need to grab the extra paint too all right draining the thinner not very bro like of you bro the first of the five jesus christ to go this way
only three more to repair where's the third or second in okay oh it's this way ow all right so where does this do hey that's dodgeball
i have this already no this is new okay what the is he i paint this or oh maybe it's for later okay so this way.
Where's the next one?
Hmm.
It's just like...
I'm just gonna ride this.
Fuck it.
Uh.
Where is the next one?
I drained it already.
It's over there?
It's fine.
I'll take a little bit of damage.
So I can get across.
Huh?
Over here?
Maybe it's over here.
It's over here.
Oh, it is.
Nice.
One more to go.
Yay, free chest.
Yay!
Alright.
Grab some HP and some blotters.
Oh, what happens?
Oh, shit.
No, never mind.
What happens to me?
I paint Oswald, though.
And whatever.
It's just all that.
Oh, it's just that.
Okay, yeah, I'm not fucking painting you anymore.
I'm gonna grab this, though.
Paint them so I can beat it up.
That's your purpose.
There's still one more.
Oh, it's over here.
Ow.
They did it.
Five!
Yay!
Born just to be beat up.
Such is life.
Yay!
I did it.
Where did that come from?
He must be guarding that projector screen behind the door.
Oh, that's easy.
Wait, before I do that, let me grab this painting real fast.
An HP too.
And refill.
Reload!
I have to reload too.
There was a lot of things I had to do.
It's time.
Open your mouth.
Say aah.
It's time.
Alright.
Gotta wait.
One more hit.
Oh, nice.
Just two.
Yay!
Refill.
Reload.
Oh, Sleeping Beauty.
What the fuck?
Wait, that's a movie.
Where the fuck did Sleeping Beauty get into my Mickey shorts?
We skipped Snow White?
Damn.
Doesn't matter if you were the first, I guess.
What the fuck, Maleficent?
it what the fuck are you doing here wait slipping beauty isn't a forgotten movie it's a fucking timeless classic what the fuck wait a minute what the fuck the sleeping beauty became a forgotten movie oh shit oh weird that it's here it's in the vault oh yeah they vaulted it
they vaulted it but you can you can buy it for the first time in in a hundred years it's you can now buy like the was it the diamond edition of sleeping beauty and just remember that when they unvaulted movies
well how do i get the v yeah they open the vault yeah how do i get that film though here oh it's here
they would do it
all the time they would make like what was it the gold edition the platinum edition and then the diamond edition.
And it worked every time.
Like, if anything, that should have been the Black Cauldron movie or level.
Not fucking Sleeping Beauty.
Like, what the fuck?
Um, Maleficent is in Sleeping Beauty is in Kingdom Hearts.
And Maleficent is one of the main enemies in there.
How is that a forgotten movie?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Look, gargoyles.
You can't turn them with your spin move.
Give it a try.
What do I do by spinning on them?
Oh.
Bean.
So waiting for Kingdom Hearts 4.
You'll just be disappointed.
Just like Kingdom Hearts 3.
Oh hey, there's his girlfriend.
Oh!
Happy and sad works.
Repairing all of one type can really change the character of the ha.
Sometimes physically, try restoring all of one set.
Aww.
Oh shit, not him again.
Just gotta go in with low expectations.
Don't be fucked up as Silk Sompi King.
Was it actually not as good?
This is why we don't get Half-Life 3.
it way too long and then people would be like and then and they don't want to disappoint people don't say that and I fucked up no after all this time don't chase it don't you know don't do this to us I pretty fucked up wouldn't it guys
oh shit okay i didn't know that's fucked up i didn't know i didn't know i i'm sorry i i didn't know i didn't know that's what it does i was like what's this i
was i was just like what's that you know what was i supposed to know it would you know do all the bad things in the room How was I supposed to know?
I thought I was doing a good thing.
I thought I was being a hero.
What's over here?
Oh, hey, it's a watch.
Already have this.
As long as I don't accidentally hit this, it should be fine.
There goes my hero.
See, this is why you go in with zero expectations.
So you won't get disappointed, guys.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, nothing.
I'll fill this up so it's like I didn't know.
It's like I didn't commit a crime.
There's a hole on the floor?
No, there's not.
There's no holes on the floor.
They don't exist.
We gotta go here, though.
Okay, I just wanted to be sure
oh okay oops don't worry i did a good thing what does that do hidden machinery oh it's the gargoyles okay but like good gargoyle or bad okay i got a pin
bad gargoyle like wood or bad oh there was a hole from here i remember you guys said there was a hole here for the tentacle where's the hole oh there is a hole oh my god i missed that oh it was a painting how do i get out oh my god it's a bad hole nobody know i noticed that i did this hide the
As long as I had the evidence, no one will know.
There's no hole on the floor.
Hey, so what do you mean?
I have no idea what you guys are talking about.
Oh, this is a mirror.
Okay, I need to burst this real fast.
Wait, is there a bad painting in here?
Oh.
Wait, but what if there's... Okay, there's nothing good on this.
painting.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god.
I didn't realize there was a bad man here.
Alright.
Okay.
I gotta make sure...
There we go.
Okay.
And then I gotta spin that guy.
And I'll spin him.
And he'll hit this.
Wait, what?
Wait, how would it...
Wait a minute.
minute.
Okay.
Let me figure this out.
Um.
Let me...
Okay.
And then he hits him over here.
What's over here?
Oh.
Have you thought about not being lonely, Oswald?
What?
Okay, and then we reflect this guy.
Where the fuck is he hitting that?
What?
Oh, there we go.
I was like, why is this not working?
Okay, and then...
Yay!
This is a good thing, right?
Yeah, it is, thank God.
I did it!
I saved the world!
Did I repair everything, though?
Are all the paintings repaired?
I don't know.
Painting done, painting.
Did I...
Did I fix everything?
I don't...
I don't know.
Are all the paintings fixed?
I can't do it!
Oh, I got the pin.
Yeah, I did.
I did.
Okay, nice.
I'm a hero.
Vantasia!
I like Vantasia.
I remember, um, I think it was, like, the second Vantasia?
Um, and my parents took me to watch it, like, at, like, a Disney World.
Oops.
Am I dead?
Okay.
How?
I don't understand.
Oh, okay, it just, I don't know, fuck me, I guess.
It didn't.
Oh, yeah, yeah, okay, there we go.
Okay, I hate, never mind, I hate Fantasia.
Never mind, never mind, fuck this level.
I, oh!
Never mind, this level fucking sucks.
Are you serious?
I timed... Oh my, fuck this.
Oh, I could have just done that.
I could have just done that.
Yeah.
Okay, now I know.
Okay, there's the film.
There's the... Wait, is there a film reel over here then?
Yes, there is.
Thank God.
I knew it.
I knew there was a film reel right here.
okay there has to be another film reel i'm oh my god are you fucking
okay now we know now we know the pattern
i i don't need that film reel i don't i don't need that film reel now that i thought okay but maybe okay but maybe maybe i can do it it's up there it's literally up there
oh my god it's literally up there it's literally right up there is it
oh my god why would there be a cloud up there if it's not up there i swear to god there there there has to be something up there i swear to there was oh my god i knew it i knew it i there was something up there.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I wasn't crazy.
There we go.
I knew it.
I could feel it in my body.
I could feel it in my bones.
Okay, nice.
Hello, Oswald.
Glad to see you can make it.
This is the Fireworks Control Center.
I use a launch on-spotted show from here.
On top of each of these three towers, there's a battery of deactivated rockets.
Activate him by climbing each tower and energize the gem you'll find there.
Once all three are done, race back here and it'll be showtime!
Even the blot won't stand a chance against all that firepower.
I'll distract him so he can scale the towers.
Let me open the doors for you!
When you're back, we'll trigger the show in remote control.
Be careful out there.
Alright, but how do we do this friendly?
Friendly.
How do we do it in a way that's friendly, Oswald?
It happens if I paint all the flowers back.
Oh, nothing happens.
Guys.
Does it...
Can I do this friendly?
There's no going back now.
Let's get to the top of the tower, Mickey.
Can I make friendly explosives?
I don't, I don't, I'm scared.
Is it possible to make friendly explosives?
Instructions unclear.
How to make explosive friendly.
Wait, why did I make it?
is it like oh oh it's like forest i see
okay we just gotta paint these real quick is there anything here i can paint it from this hole guys i can't paint it from this hole
okay gotta give him his skin tear routine oh shit
Hit.
Get that tentacle.
Whoops.
There's something up here, but can I even get there?
Hello, guys.
How do I get up there?
Uh.
Oh, we're endgame right now.
Okay.
Can delete the door.
I learned this in that pirate thing.
Alright, door deleted.
I didn't realize Oswald had so many chandeliers.
Yeah, fucking freak.
Oh, it's right here.
Yay!
The silver pin!
Alright, nice.
Yeah, I just got...
Okay.
Oh, come on, come on.
Make it, make it.
Yes!
I'm faster.
Nice.
And now we're here.
Wait, this looks like Kingdom Hearts.
It looks like that...
That exact level in Kingdom Hearts where you have to go up the lair thing.
The Wizard's Tower.
Oh my god, it is Kingdom Hearts.
What?
Oh, shit.
He's here to help me.
I don't think him being so powerful.
We're scary.
Please.
Hurry, Mickey.
I'm getting there as fast as I can, sir.
Oh!
I'm nice.
I made it.
Oh, shit.
Shit!
Oh my god!
Oh, clutch, clutch.
Very clutch.
Why can't I paint that?
It's coming atop Argarios that you can rotate.
You'll have to hit them to make them turn, then paint in their heads.
Okay, they have to be paying to become active.
Whoa!
Wait, you can't open his mouth!
How am I supposed to give him the juice?
Oh, shit!
Guys, I don't think he wants the juice.
I think I'm just supposed to activate this.
Wait, that's not fair!
Okay, and then I have to paint the head.
Okay.
Is it friendly?
Is this friendly thing to do?
Oh!
Is he?
Is he friend?
It's blue!
That's blue juice!
It's the friend beam!
Okay.
All right.
And now I just have to do that three more two more times.
The friendship.
It's blue!
Blue friend!
Okay, I just have to do that two more times.
Friend beam.
okay that was friendly right as friendly as explosives can be that has to be friendly it's blue oh it's the pink it's uh it's them it's them it's the little mobs it's the mob man
ow what the fuck is this hit what the fuck do we have like 100 on smash or some shit what the fuck was that ricochet could mickey confirm his smash bros
okay nice oh my god the film reel is from there No, that was bullshit.
It literally, like, sent me, like, 800 meters.
Mickey confirmed on Smash.
What the fuck?
He's not stopping.
What's wrong with you?
Oh, I can...
Oh, I can kill him.
Okay.
That's what's wrong with him.
I didn't know I could fucking kill him.
Technically, I'm not a murderer when he's not even, like...
when he's not technically he has no brain it's not murder when he's already a vegetable
i don't know what i open
all right let's go up yeah wow joki there you go yay he's not even a sentient being
all right here we go Gotta do this again.
I'm lawful good, guys.
So good.
I'm so good that, like, they need to create a new category for me for how lawful I am.
Let's open this chest.
Alright.
Up I go.
Yay!
What?
Oh my god, the darkness is coming.
Oh my god.
Sora, Where are you?
The darkness are coming!
The heartless are here!
Ow!
Okay, how the fuck was I supposed to know it would do that?
Yeah.
What happened?
Oh shit, hello!
Oh, I mean, hi.
I mean, that's nice of them to just say hi to me, I guess.
Trying to say hi.
Jesus Christ, it's just...
It's destroying the entire real estate.
The property value is going to go down, man.
How are we going to resell?
Oh!
I'm okay.
Oh, it's time.
It's friendship beam time.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
We're okay.
Beam!
God, we're beaming.
We're beaming.
We're forcing friendships.
The doky way.
Friendship beam!
Get out!
That's right!
Take my friendship!
All right, one more.
One more friendship.
beam.
Take it!
Okay.
Let's grab HP real quick, and that should be good.
One more.
One more love bomb.
For the ride.
Yes.
Because it's how you make friends, guys.
It's just that easy.
Okay.
Oh
Please no Oh shit, it's time.
Oh shit.
I thought it'll go back down.
Okay, I can't fuck around here I didn't realize this was actually time
The water is actually coming up
Okay, but there might be a film here So that it's worth it I actually like What was the point of going up here?
I think it's fine I don't think I need another film anyway Oh my god Why is it so fast?
Why did it become so fast?
Okay, that's fine Yeah, we're going about We just dropped That was that I saw the water just travel exponentially faster That's why we don't need the film We can't even go back to like the usher anyway We already got everything we need anyway
I'm pretty sure the film doesn't affect it Doesn't affect the good or bad
Alright up we go Yay One last tower It's the final countdown, everyone.
It's supposed to be here.
What do I do now?
Hello?
What?
Oh, did I jump?
Here?
Oh!
Oh, cheeky.
Oh, never mind.
No, it's a trap.
I was like, oh, cheeky, that's so smart.
No, I just fell for a trap.
It was a trap all along.
This way.
Actually, I needed that.
That's good.
I needed to refill my pain anyway.
Cheeky trap indeed.
Fine, I got refill.
I reloaded.
Oh, almost got me.
Okay, now it's more fighting.
Alright, I'll use this on the mob.
Okay, that's not the mob.
Aim assist failed.
Now they're trapped in here with me.
Wait, you're...
Why are you fighting each other?
I thought you're friends.
I didn't get the refill.
Okay, you're right.
I didn't have the red eyes, so the...
The aim assistant didn't work.
Hmm, is it worth it?
Ah, fuck it.
Oh my god, imagine if I got on the wrong platform, and then this thing dropped.
And I just see the red chest fall down.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Alright, grab the chest.
Okay, let's get the little gesture men.
Okay.
That's what we wanted.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Now we just pour it.
Open wide.
Nice.
That's good.
They're hitting them, not me.
Say ah.
That's right.
Ah.
Okay, one more hit.
Yay.
What?
Guys, please.
Please.
I just, please.
We're trying to make him our friend.
Guys, please.
Please.
Oh my god, you're worthless.
You're actually worthless.
Okay, now he's my friend.
Yay.
Let's go.
all the pain, guys.
Maybe it is a little bad that they're eating paint.
Sometimes having too many friends is not the right answer.
Up we go.
Alright.
Final friendship beam.
Something doesn't feel right.
Wait, you're right.
Where did he go?
Wait, am I supposed to activate the friendship beam?
Where is he?
Wait a minute.
Where's the...
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Something feels sus.
Back to the fireworks control tower.
Alright.
Where did he go?
Where am I beaming it to?
Oh, the bolt is in here.
Did he figure out what I was doing?
Oh my god, how did they figure it out?
Is it the fireworks on the towers?
There's no way.
How did he know?
How could he have possibly No, I wonder.
No.
You think he saw the fireworks?
Oh, shit.
Down I go.
Who leaked it?
Oswald!
Oh, fuck.
What?
Painting.
What the fuck do I do?
Down I'll go.
Oh, hey, Anvil.
Am I?
Am I supposed to do anything?
Or am I just fucked?
Am I just falling to my death?
Stream sniping?
No way.
Couldn't have.
Oh my god, he's stream sniping me.
Skydiver pit.
I don't think...
Smacking into my face, my face into the wall is considered skydiving.
Okay, we need to get to Oswald.
Oh shit!
Okay, now, now we can get to Oswald.
How do we get to Oswald?
What?
How the fuck do I get to him?
Hello?
Oh, here.
Yeah, because I was like, excuse me?
Where the fuck do I go?
Okay, let's grab this pin real quick.
Yay!
Silver pin!
Okay, I don't know why I destroyed it.
I might not have been very smart of me to do.
What did I do?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Wait, which way do I go?
Okay, I went that way.
Okay.
Come on.
I can make it.
Nice.
I'm gaming.
Alright, I made it.
What's over here?
Oh, shit.
It was like that when I got here, guys.
I swear to God.
It was like that when I got here.
The platform was already collapsed.
Why is it all green paint?
I didn't touch anything.
I didn't pull any lever, chat, I swear.
Yay!
My gold pin!
I don't even know why I'm collecting these any.
I'm like thinking, wait, maybe collecting these pins have been pretty pointless.
Like, what the fuck am I doing?
I could have finished this game like three hours ago if I fucking stopped collecting pins.
There is a tentacle here, but...
Oh, okay, I was gonna stay.
Please.
All right, get down.
Maybe.
Yay!
I did it.
All right.
Let's patch this tentacle up.
We're almost there.
Ah!
Shit.
So I can get my 91 premium.
completion rate.
And they grab my HP back.
Oswald, I'm back!
I made it!
Oh, that's his girlfriend!
There she is.
That works already!
Uh-huh!
Great job.
Batteries are dead.
I'll replace them in a jiffy.
That should have been the first thing they did.
It's not a statue.
That's...
what's left over after we balled up the ball I'm so sorry I messed up oh you didn't mean to for a while I didn't mean to the rocket never mind I made my share of misses seems we both need some forgiveness wait any more confessions I forgive you for killing my wife
Oh!
Oswald!
That's like crazy that he just forgives him for killing his girlfriend like that.
Oh my god, bro, she's just a stand- that's when you know he's evil.
He's like, yeah, your girlfriend's a statue now, but like, you know what?
Fuck you, I'm grabbing her too.
Oswald should have told Mickey, like, let me turn your girlfriend into a statue and then we're even.
Yeah, I know, like, why the girlfriend as well?
like she's already technically dead it's like going to her grave and just decide to like dig up her body and then burn it that's how fucked up it was oh I'm inside him nice
oh sweet I'm inside him now
devoured village
yeah You go back to sleep, sir.
I've become your friend.
And I sleep forever.
Alright.
Oh, hello.
Boy, am I glad to see you.
I got separated from Oswald after the bloke grabbed us.
I think we're inside.
See, we're inside him.
The bloke.
And the bloke grabbed me.
I dropped the remote.
Unless Oswald found it.
It's gone forever.
I'm sorry.
From now on, I'll follow you in the help whenever I can.
Lead on.
Alright.
I swear, these guys have not been threatening at all.
All they do is just leave.
Like, I don't know what their purpose is.
They just leave.
Yeah, it's gold pin.
My 91% completion rate is down 91.1%.
I think I was not missing up here.
No.
We're literally just chilling.
Yeah.
Oh, that's my heart.
That's a big-ass fucker.
looking hard, Mickey.
Before capitalism got you.
That appears to be your heart.
That means the vault can enter your world when he gains enough strength.
You must take it back before it happens.
There.
That's the honorable point on when the bloodicle is holding your heart.
Oh, there's Oswald!
It'll be okay.
We can lock, but we must hurry.
He was such a sweet kid before capitalism, guys.
Wait, how the fuck was he already, like, on my side?
Oh, wait, look, there he is just sleeping.
He literally didn't do anything.
He just slept.
That's crazy.
Alright.
Anything else here?
Wait, that's it?
Oh, do I have to go up?
I must have to go up now.
Oh, yeah, there it is.
What the fuck?
Can I, like, turn them into good people?
Is he turning blue?
Guys, I don't think they're turning blue.
Guys, I don't think they're turning blue, guys.
Guys, guys!
Guys, I'm...
Oh,
don't!
Ah!
I don't know what happened!
I just got stuck!
I got stuck, Sepra.
I don't know what happened.
It just...
It just got stuck.
That's fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
Wait, how do I...
Thing is that I'm pretty sure I can get across there.
Oh yeah, there's a painting.
Yeah, I'm just gonna sit there.
What about here?
Bum bum bum bum.
Like, what is being up here for?
Wait, somebody's sleeping.
Be very, very quiet.
Somebody ZZ-Z-Zing right now.
I guess there's nothing here?
What the fuck was the point of being up there?
Alright.
This is fine.
Okay, I don't know if I'm...
If I can...
I don't think I'm supposed...
to kill them?
I think that...
I don't know.
It doesn't feel like a good thing to do.
I'll just let them chill.
No, if I use thinner, that's bad.
Holy shit.
Holy shit, they kill themselves.
I'll just walk away.
The power of just walking away.
Let's take Technically, I didn't kill them.
Cartoon characters consumed by the bullet.
Technically, I'm not killing them.
I just walk away.
So I didn't commit any crime.
If you just walk away, there's no crime committed.
You're just ignoring the problem.
And that's different.
I'm just a bystander.
Oh, it's all the Pete's.
You're honest, she just walked away.
I hope that free them somehow.
Wait, did I free them?
I free them.
You said hopefully that frees them.
And like, that's good?
I don't know.
He said, hopefully.
I'm believing in that hope.
I freed them in a way.
Will I help you go to sleep at night?
Jesus.
He's like, wow.
Looks like the blood are spawning defenses.
Those splatters are like his antibodies.
And we are the virus.
That's why we got one.
We can get more.
It's fine.
I feel like my fucking pain should be stronger, too.
Alright, last one.
We got him in the corner.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I think they're friends now?
Question mark?
Okay, nice.
Okay, let me try.
Maybe eventually...
Guys, it doesn't look like he's...
Guys, I don't think it's working.
It's okay.
I'm not hitting them.
So I'm not doing anything bad.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's just there.
Okay, it's fine.
I have the high ground.
You can't get me.
It's okay.
I have the high ground.
You couldn't get me.
That's right, Anakin.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I know they apparently can't stand on ledge.
They can, like, go up, so I can literally just chill here.
I'll just chill here.
Because they can't reach me.
See, look at them.
Look at these guys.
I'm just chilling.
What's over here?
Oh, nothing.
Nothing to worry about.
As long as I have, as long as I have, like, one center meters above ground, they can't get me.
Yay!
I'm truck.
Have money.
Mushy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm like your retail retail therapy
all right one last one for the ride how the fuck did they get here all right they're both friends now oh they're both friends now nice just
standing there taking it.
Ow!
What the fuck?
Oh, he's summoning more defenses!
Wait, which ones are the bad and which one?
There's so many of them.
Which one's good and which one's bad?
Oh my god, they're just beating each other up.
I can't tell.
They're just beating each other up.
Nice.
All right, the last heart.
Hold the light.
They don't even know.
They're like, are you good, Jerry?
No, he's a good one.
I already converted him.
But the power of paint
is...
Pop!
God that sound when it goes like it's so fucking loud trying to have high ground here all right the last one quick seal the kill hole okay high ground all right where's the next one wait where's the next one where's the next paint nice Wait, where is it?
Wait, where is it?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, it's hidden underneath here.
Clever dread.
And then the next one is here.
Oh hey!
Alright.
And then we go up.
That's right, you can't catch me.
That's right.
Yay!
Oh, dude, yeah, I'm Osmosis-Jonesing right now.
Oh, damn, will the world be safe from the blot?
Yay!
My heart!
Greetings, fellow blots.
Have you heard of my Lord and Savior, Jesus Christ, and let him into your hearts?
Ha-ha!
Okay, I'll go this way.
I hope those guys exploded out of friendship.
Because that would be very awkward if they didn't.
All right.
Down I go.
Open up.
Yay!
Oh, shit.
Just one more, and I can see it's a weak point right there.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
Where did he?
He just spawns in it behind me.
What the fuck is going?
He literally just spawns it.
It spawns in behind you.
Okay.
That should be fine.
He just spawns it.
Alright.
Very slowly.
I gotta wait.
This sucks because he's closing his mouth because of the other guys with me.
So I have to actually fucking wait.
Please just open your mouth longer!
Please stop slapping!
Please, sir!
I need you to stop slapping!
Oh my god, a fucking curse, a fucking curse.
You have to, you line up like that perfect the perfect angle to fuck me over.
A fucking curse you did.
Oh my god, they can't, they don't stop.
Okay.
Okay, there There we go.
There we go.
Now we're okay.
Holy shit.
How many are there?
Wait, he died.
Wait, he fucking died.
Oh no, he's over there.
Alright, just a few more left.
Where's the last one?
Hello?
Oh, it's in this corner.
Oh, that's diabolical.
Right?
in that corner.
Last shot.
Oh, shit!
I'm sorry!
It was a love tap.
Yay!
I got an epic journey achievement!
Is that good?
That's good, Enre?
Come on, Oswald.
Kill your girlfriend if you don't give my heart back.
Nothing can stop me.
Yay!
All I have to do is just push the statue and it's gone.
Don't make me push it.
Yay!
Power fireworks!
Friendship explosion.
Here you go, friend.
Getting my hot bag.
The intruder returned to my lab, but not in the way I expected.
After retrieving my brush, I peered down into the world I had created and noticed something had changed.
Oh, it's Oswood.
The wasteland no longer needed my magic.
Oh, thanks to the efforts of my apprentice it had developed some magic.
Yeah Magic born of courage And wise choices.
I did it good ending.
Oh my god, see I tried so hard to be good and I did it I fucking did it Bum bum bum I actually am a Good person, guys.
That didn't break?
Wait, that's all?
We could have just painted her back?
That's...
That's the Oswald.
You're such a fucking idiot.
Feeling enemies never affected the ending, by the way.
Kina, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I have to do?
He's banished.
Yay!
They're happy now.
The way is defeated or redeemed.
The ways in which we treat others.
and perhaps most important the friendships oh yes on the mysteries he saw oh there's goofy
yeah he's got some oh my look this is his girlfriend that's right and perhaps more perhaps even brothers
he's like you want to watch
that's my girlfriend you want to watch
Matthew Matthew thank you for the super chat thank you congrats on beating epic Mickey I grabbed 20 e-tickets.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The power of friendship.
Oh my god, we did it.
What in it?
Oh my, I haven't had it.
I haven't done a non-Marvel Rival as Endurance Stream in a long fucking time.
Oh my.
It did not feel like I was playing for seven hours, but I was losing steam at the last hour.
I'm not.
I think it did help that I kept getting stuck.
on the dumbest puzzles um but we fucking did it guys we beat epic mickey oh my god after like coming back after three weeks i was like we're i we can't do another part we have to just rip the bed we just gotta go we just gotta finish it today why do vtubers always say thank you thank you much you think of the super chat thank you thank you because we're very thankful uh yeah i was just like we can't delay the anymore we i gotta tank it i some collectibles are locked in a bad ending sadly that's fine i'm okay with my 91 percent completion rate is there an after credit scene chat um is there an after credit scene for this game for the game uh but i'm glad to finally finish epic mickey it was a game that i wanted to play for a long time i hope they make it i hope they make it a remaster for Epic Mickey 2 because uh I know Epic Mickey 2 is co-op what I really want for the second game is that it's like online multiplayer so like because you know how like Epic Mickey 2 is split screen um I
hope they make uh I hope they'd make it like uh give an option for a non-local co-op so you can actually play it with like online multiplayer um yeah no it does have a sequel Mickey tail for the Wii U, I believe.
Yeah, they give a super chat.
Thank you.
Toki, to make it a real endurance stream, replay the game for the...
No, the bad ending is actually really crazy.
Like, Mickey literally just destroys the whole village.
I don't remember, like, the reason...
I don't know.
There's no reason for him.
I mean, it's Mickey Mouse that...
Is there really a reason?
I mean...
basically like a reflection of current Disney.
Uh, Nephirs, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, but yeah, is there an after after credit scene, guys?
Yeah, he just has a, he literally becomes Disney, yeah.
Is Epic Mickey 2 that bad?
I never, I never played Epic Mickey.
I mean, I never played Epic Mickey in general.
Um, Vinny, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hello, Doki.
Congrats on finishing Epic Mickey.
I also finally the youtube's jokey plush it's adorable high quality and oddly hugable thank you for such an amazing plus and all that youtube thank you benny thank you for the super chat thank you thank you no thank you guys for the support i know like um this final playthrough might not be like you know um um not a lot of people were were like uh um excited to watch part three of epic mickey but i'm always happy to finish a game i had a fun time i personally had a fun time playing And I normally don't play a lot of platformers,
too.
And it was a game that I've been wanting to play for a while now.
So I'm glad to add another game in my completed list.
I'm always...
I always want to complete, like...
I like completing games.
Yeah, they missed out on the fun facts, guys.
All the fun facts and fun stories.
And they missed out on data updates.
I always, I always slip in the most crucial data updates on these type of streams.
So you can't, you shouldn't, don't miss out.
You sound so tired.
I am.
I mean, I streamed for seven hours today.
My schedule is so fucked.
I think it's because it's like both jet lag and like, I've had like so much stuff to do because I've been trying to catch up on things.
uh incredible like my sleep schedule is just all over the place i also had a 4 a.m rehearse like tech rehearsal for um the fake trigger gamescom thing today too so um i took a nap woke up at 1 a.m had to stay up till 4 a.m to do the rehearsal the tech rehearsal and then like um went back to sleep um and woke up at like what like 12 ish i think 12 p.m um yeah that's why i posted my at three in the fucking morning.
But yeah, for those who don't know, I'll be streaming the fake trigger thing.
But like, we're going to be broadcast also in Germany.
So like, we're playing with people who are at the fake trigger games con booth.
And like, you know how like I have my chat up on my top right.
So whatever you, like, they'll be able to see the stream.
Like, they'll be able to see the stream and stuff.
Which is funny because like, I'm fighting the...
people at the games con booth so like what's stopping them from like stream sniping me like like now that i think about it like they can just stream snip me because i literally be on the screen while they like they can just look at like because like the like the the stream of me playing the game is literally in front of them like in front of all the people that will be playing the game so so they'll just look up and then see exactly where I am it's it's the challenge now I was like I was like wait a minute now that I think about it wait oh yeah yeah um oh yeah i have to play on eu ping too um so um so i mean we'll have it's me and rpr rpr is apparently like at the um at the venue playing and then we're gonna grab two people that gets assigned to us for a squad so like i don't know i'll just be the heel bot again it's not even 120 it's like it's like 150 or some shit because i'm west coast so it's um i'm west coast so i get more ping to eu than um than um uh asia yeah he'll it's okay
all i have to do is just press q that's it that's really fun i really enjoyed Epic Mickey.
Tomorrow is the Sloppy Sisters collab with Lamo, Mint, and Snuffy.
So we're going to be playing Majorina and then yeah, at least I get to sleep.
Oh, I can't sleep in.
Now that Dad's back, I can't sleep in anymore.
Which, by the way, I gotta feed Dad later.
Because he needs to eat food.
He hasn't been like...
He hasn't been demanding food, which is nice.
I think it's because like...
I think because he's like a chonky boy now he doesn't get as hungry um because he has so much you know he has so much fat on him now so he doesn't get as hungry easily i don't know how it works actually maybe that's not how it works but he hasn't barked at me for food today which is nice because usually in the before before he was at the dog sitter um yeah he's finally i don't know if that's how it works i don't have a medical degree um I got my meta degree revoked after Battlefield 6 for some reason.
I don't know why I saved lives.
Yeah, he has fat reserves, so maybe that's why he's not as demanding for food lately.
I don't know how I lost my medical license.
I saved so many lives there.
I know I was a hero
It says combat medic I was just trying to Make sure I was both a medic and a combat And in combat by the way Literally the TF2 medic Holy shit A lot of people worked on this I love the artwork though The artwork's really pretty I wish I bought the I think like I I wish I bought the Epic Mickey art books I love art books though I love like seeing all the concept art of stuff um wasn't this game wasn't the game company for this from Hong Kong right I don't know maybe I'm making shit up I don't remember but it was either like Hong Kong or somewhere else in China.
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like for the development for this.
At chat.
Fact check me right now.
I don't know, but I will believe this and spread this.
I saw that Or maybe a programming Split in chat Is this true?
At chat Say Studio is based in Texas Close enough
I almost got that right guys I love spreading misinformation guys
powerhouse and yeah Texas China maybe there's a Texas Street in Hong Kong you know it could be it's like how um there's like American cities that are just taken from like other places in the world.
Oh, the other serial is Shenzhen.
I knew it!
See?
How long is next to Shenzhen?
If I was playing Geogesser, I would have won.
It would have given me points if I was playing Geogesser.
VP, Global Brand Marketing, Director, Internal Development, Producer, Associate, Producer, is the credits repeating itself or wait are the credits repeating itself
oh i don't know no okay thank god okay because i was like wait i've seen have i seen this art before okay thank god i was gonna it's in a don't oh it's just long okay thank god okay i was gonna say i swear to god if the credits are repeating itself and i didn't know because i was like wait why are they showing the why are they showing these the constant art for the world for these worlds when we've already when they show the constant part for the the the guy that bored us because that would have been that should have been the end you know the guy that bored us
but um but um but i am very tired And hunggy.
I'm hunggy and tired.
A double whammy.
War is never the end.
It's just the beginning.
Aren't you the one that's drunk right now?
I mean...
Spoken like a real drunk man.
I'll eat after the stream.
I've been watching...
You know what is it?
Oh, I've been watching norm of the north lately because it's on disney plus um thank god hulu is coming to disney plus because like less subscriptions you know thank god um but i've been watching norm norm of the north which is like it's basically like it's like by the studio who made bob's burgers um but like they have all the a-list comedy actors and actresses um voice acting the show because they have Will Forte,
um, that guy in, in Parks and Rec, the, the, the manager guy from Parks and Rec with a mustache.
I forgot his actual name.
Um, if you ever watch Parks and Rec, you'll know the guy I'm talking about, but the, the mustache guy from Parks and Rec, he's in it.
And then they have, um, what's her name?
Yeah, oh yeah, Nick, they have Ron Swanson.
Oh, hey.
Hey.
Hello.
That's here.
And they have the...
What's the other girl?
What's the girl's name?
Where she's like, Don't be suspicious.
Don't.
Don't be suspicious.
That girl, she's in Norm of the North.
And then Ron Swanson's crazy ex-wife.
I forgot her name.
But, you know, the librarian.
A lot of people from Parks and Rec are in there Now that I realize Oh hey Oh sorry Mickey Can't watch Mickey will get into no more mischief in my Tammy yeah The crazy one She's in it Mickey Mouse Yay Why are you What the fuck You became like an ink bender Or some shit It's Chris Pratt there Chris Pratt is like he has such a big ego now he got super fucking religious that's he got incredibly religious um but anyway we did it alright I'm gonna head off now guys I'm Eepy but thank you all for watching I hope you had a fun time with me today finishing Epic Mickey yeah he became a fucking inkbender in finishing Epic Mickey grab some food and relax now as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye